ah c'est le coeur salut tout le monde
donc femmes troisième journée de cette
compétition
qu'est ce que t'en as pensé de la
journée d'hier du coup bas je pensais
que j'étais le chat noir en fait je
commente le premier jour on gagne rien
des routeurs jeu par deux victoires
ouais deux victoires et la victoire
contre l'inde fab elle a été à l'arraché
total à au forceps avec eux on était un
peu engluée dans ce match et puis qu'il
ait les vannes gelé fin de partie il
enferme le foie de l'air c'est tout ça
ouais très très jolie feinte de partir
est très très jolie fin de partie la
part de levon qui a gagné une partie qui
ne devait pas gagner qui devait
peut-être pas perdre mais où il était
mal on the match qui a bien tourné
partout infâme
oui ma des postes comme ça pour me
retomber à reprendre
ouais les puits puis les états unis
écoute c'est un beau succès contre un
concurrent direct pour la qualif
alors après perso j'ai pas trop compris
la composent les états unis de sortir
caruana qui est des deux points sur deux
sera pas faire un jeu un joueur
dominguez veut dire que quand on est
plus fort mais là encore on va prendre
d'ailleurs ce qui est marrant c'est que
2 min 11 ans et ça a été ou ça s est
toujours l'entraîneur est tirée seconde
en deux de fabiano et du coup c'est
marrant que qu'il fasse jouer
l'entraîneur à la place tu voir coacher
quoi n'est pas ce qui me faisait jouer
du pichichi la dose rogers way mon fils
et mon service
meba il a fini comme maxime donc quelque
part peut-être en fait il mérite un vrai
on ne sait pas on ne sait pas mais donc
voyez choix bizarre mais voilà on prend
écoute aujourd'hui donc le reste du
monde va falloir s'appliquer puisque
c'est l'équipe supposée la plus faible
ou avec l'inde en tout cas les deux
équipes les plus faibles donc il faut
vraiment gagner ça va être serré la
chine semble s'envoler et après deuxième
match contre la russie qui sera
primordial non mais en fait chaque
journée bien sûr importante mais grâce à
la journée d'hier
l'europe qui ressort donc la tête de
l'eau et qui a donc toujours toutes ses
chances pour pour la qualif est le
favori donc incontesté et incontestable
reste la chine va confirme la chine
confirme ils ont gravi noir un nul soit
peut être que non ils sont
impressionnants et vous mr très sérieuse
très compacte vraiment ils seront très
très très dur à battre
ouais je sais pas quand on les rejoue à
deux mains je crois c'était notre
deuxième match donc on va les jouer
demain en premier en même temps ce ne
sera pas la même il faudra vraiment
s'accrocher contre eux et il faudra
prendre les points les points autour fab
exactement exactement
donc tu veux qu'on essaye de se lancer
un petit peu sur sur les compos du jour
si elles sont arrivées on va voir ça
alors ça c'est pas là celle qui nous
intéresse en premier lieu voilà donc
l'équipe d'europe qui aligne maxime
vachier lagrave au premier alireza
firoud aronian aux deux contres
ferroudja anish giri aux trois qui
remplace duda marrant à cette situation
de guiry mais peut-être finalement
guerrier a compris que ça aille mieux le
faire vous avec les noirs peut-être
parce que avec les blancs s'étaient pas
et est ce que les chinois ils tournent
tout le temps aussi où ils mettent leur
équipe type des fois tout le temps non
il tourne donc tout le monde tourne en
fait ouais tout le monde tourne et au
dernier chic et comme prévu hier les
soeurs musique foot sont sortis des deux
côtés est normal qu'elles s'affrontent
pas section dentelle joue le font match
nul de scba et raymond sachant que du
coup tu n'allais pas moins de l'année
oui et du non versement et du coup elle
se joue
ça aurait pu être marrant j'ai dit que
je n'étais pas en fait je la mets du
coup c'est les laudes fait la même chose
à pas de chance
bon match nul en année l'échiquier mais
il ya des blancs dans cet échiquier
d'ailleurs servi en europe n'atteint zag
needs et qui aura les pièces blanches
pabx contre dinara sadou à caso va
entraîner par par une légende wayne
gendarmes lundi sauf catcheur ouais donc
forcément forcément jouer sa dangereuse
je pense qu'on n'est pas favori sur cet
échiquier
même si on a plus de points elo est sur
le papier soit disant des favoris
entraîneur légendaire très dur très dur
on verra on verra ce qui se passe mais
c'est vrai qu'on aura forte affaire ou 4
et affrontements aussi sympa aux
premières échiquier du coup on peut
revenir dessus
maxime vachier lagrave donc numéro un
français qui vont à contre team ou
radjabov qui n'a pas joué le les
candidats parce qu'il avait peur du
clovis 19
ouais exactement et maxime l'a remplacé
et donc du coup les devoirs qui se
rencontrent leurs après n'y a pas
d'animosité entre les deux autres
soldats baup s'est retiré il savait bien
que quelqu'un veut prendre sa place pour
n'importe qui alors ce qui est marrant
c'est que ces radjabov qui avait éliminé
à maxime on coupe du monde au québec
grâce à la coupe du monde en éliminant
maxime et c'est la première fois qu'ils
se rend compte depuis depuis cette
élimination
exactement ils ont des petits comptes à
régler on va dire et ouais investisseurs
des candidats y coûte je sais pas ce que
ça donnera je sais pas quand ça pourra
éventuellement reprendre ou jamais dur à
dire
ça dépend pas de nous africains
reprennent en allemagne oui par exemple
mais bon le foot reprendre au début j'ai
vu ça après coup on commence à marcher
ensemble
oui mais ça a failli y arriver ils
reprennent très clairement mais oui donc
mais bon reprenons rejoue en jouant les
candidats à merlin en reprenant à berlin
parce qu'avant réussi en russie c'est
pas gagné
non aussi j'ai vu que c'est pas gagné
c'est pas c'est pas dans un avenir
proche si va le refaire en russie savait
que ça pourrait durer
mais je pense aussi qu'au delà de ça il
faut que la même en 10 rigoler un petit
peu en parlant de l'allemagne mais les
joueurs russes auraient du mal à se
déplacer en allemagne etc dans tous les
cas même un joueur comme kahone à ce
qu'ils auraient le droit de se déplacer
à l'étranger
il ya plein de problèmes à tous les
étages oui oui
donc je leur parlais comme c'est une
compétition internationale est pas
nationale ça va être beaucoup plus
compliqué de reprendre le tronc à des
candidats d'autres qu'autre chose mais
écoute on espère que ça reprendra cette
année de tout de même parce que sinon
après si ça c'est un gros un gros laps
de temps entre le entre la première et
la deuxième moitié
ça pourrait ça pourrait vraiment
largement fausser la compétition
bon disons c'est déjà faux c'est de me
créer des jeux chaque joueur qui base sa
fausse un peu plus on va dire ça comme
ça
oui mais c'est à deux trois mois c'est
une chose si tu as un an et demi ou une
boisson gauche pense que ce serait
peut-être plus malins d'annuler de
repartir c'est un dossier qui est ce que
ta mère à une saison blanche
bah oui non pas lui qui est censé avoir
déjà du monde en 2022 aussi et bien
suite 2020 si le temps passe plus la
joie en fin 2021 bas autant dire le sud
2022 et puis tant pis poursuit d'avant
je le ferai une possibilité
effectivement suivant suivant sur
combien de dans combien de temps on peut
reprendre la compétition fabien
exactement mais bon après ba souhaitons
que ça puisse jouer dès le mois de
septembre tout allait bien dans le
meilleur des mondes
oui oui on espère tous un que ça puisse
reprendre rapidement
ce trois des candidats en tout cas c'est
qu'il ya des joueurs si on reprenait les
nationalités des gens des candidats et à
quoi deux joueurs qui viennent de chine
3 3 joueurs russes un français un
américain et il me manque le hollandais
guéri voilà et voilà donc bah en fait un
peu des dents toute la planète
plusieurs continents
représentait donc en ce temps pas
évidents
les normes sont les mêmes partout les
droits sont les mêmes partout et c'est
un instinct je peux te dire que les
joueurs européens sont installés fab
on va essayer de voir ce que ça donne
alors là c'est pas maxime vachier
lagrave à la caméra on va le récupérer
notre maxime un cadre beaucoup moins
puisqu'il se veut certes non alors c'est
pas lui le truc c'est que normalement
j'attends de voir si l'as quatre caméras
ou cinq écoutes ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va se dire que maxime brèthes là
je veux juste dire le bien le dire le
reprendre môssieur gabon mieux ouais tu
te cadre mieux ici est atteint je vais
bien me reprendre parce que le truc
c'est qu'ils changent ils sont quatre
ils sont cinq des fois ils sont six donc
ce qu'on va faire on va pas s'embêter
on va bien le remette note maxime tu vas
voir
voilà comme ça on le voit bien et on va
suivre ça parti suisse à partie
complètement donc maxime qui varient et
pièces quoirin ouais c'est plutôt une
bonne opération d'ailleurs pour la team
europe je pense femme parce que
rattraper un joueur très solide
oui donc faru avec les noirs bons jeunes
et ainsi une bonne opération on a à nice
guy ritchie et 3 qui aura les nordiques
est notre joueur solide attitré de
l'équipe et donc blanche pour un rognant
échiquier 2 qui était donc hier le héros
de la journée et pour nana les anims
échiquier 4 qui en sa chance
oui du coup je dirais que les couleurs
sont dues sont du bon côté pour l'équipe
européenne mais après on se rappelle que
maxime avait perdu avec les pièces
noires 1 contre radjabov non sept
matches décisifs delà de la coupe du
monde devrait donc méfiance méfiance
quand même au premier a répliqué pour le
moment que des nuls un premier accueil à
maxime qu'il était solide qui annihile
ses adversaires bon cela nier lui aussi
tout le monde ça ni loyale
voilà non mes appareils appareil a pas
vraiment été en danger il n'a pas
vraiment mis ses adversaires en danger
non plus voilà peut-être un petit peu
compte nepomniachi non il avait eu un
rebond des bonus
ouais il a sûrement pu gagner d'ailleurs
oui mais si ça c'est pas une pression
qu'il a réussi à maintenir très
longtemps non non non non exactement
c'est vrai que ça s'est vite envolée
david transposant une finale deux tours
je me souviens qu'il ya vert promet
toews et puis en fait quelques coups
plus tard
bah c'était juste égal mais dans ce but
il a été beaucoup plus dangereux comme
l'épopée de partis ou les joues et et 4
contres qu'on digne par exemple oui
hélas il avait rien d'autre
il avait rien obtenu et contre contre
allende avec les noirs en revanche s'il
avait il a passé facilement annulé ce
billet avec ce petit slave nouvelle
ouverture oui là il n'avait pas été
spécialement en danger contre contre
vichy donc non on peut dire que
globalement c'était des partis qui sont
toujours plus ou moins rester dans la
normalité mais l'otan mais contribue
aussi passe pas alors il a eu une petite
pression en donner il était probablement
un peu mieux mais pareil ça a duré deux
trois coups et rapidement la position
est allée à faire vers une nulle donc on
peut pas vraiment dire qu'il y ait eu un
instant où maxime ailleurs un avantage
s'est pas enflammé dans le bon et va
gagner et tout ça non mais après il fait
le boulot en l'équipe européenne qui est
sûrement vu
niveau d'arreau niane de du troisième
expliqué sur la grille soit ou tard on
est probablement plus favoris aux deux
ou trois équipes donc maxime qui a un
rôle de stoppeur quelque part mais
souvent c'est une stratégie utilisée
dans les olympiades par certaines
équipes en fait d'envoyer un mec au
premier échiquier pour cadenasser le
leader adverse
et puis aussi de secouristes qui
intermédiaire c'est ce que fait ce que
fait l'équipe européenne ouais avec pour
le moment du succès puisque ils ont deux
victoires et une nulle pour une seule
défaite et défaite contre la chine donc
elle n'a pas à rougir
d'ailleurs en parlant de la chine fab
est ce que tu veux qu'on jette un oeil à
leurs compos du jour des amis chinois
alors tout comme dingli à rennes wang
hao et yu yang qui donc tu vois il
tourne un petit peu avec avec oui mais
c'est gros match c'est de chine est
devenue ils refont jeu dominguez ok mais
ils sont jeunes et erwan ah oui mais ça
c'est logique il va écoute du coup qu'il
ya des blancs dans ce match alors c'est
hikaru nakamura qui aura les blancs au
premier échiquier pour l'équipe des
états unis face à digby rennes c'est un
duel qui annonce un feu d'artifice
femmes
je crois que la chine devrait aussi de
tout cadenassé et où tout jouer sur
iphone
ouais ça semble être la stratégie nord
ou encore que wang hao peut-être un peu
tenté un contre 40 la bizarre qu'elle
leur fait sortir caruana hier et de le
faire rentrer au moment où il ya du
manga ou un joueur qui lui réussit pas
trop aux deux c'est bien un choix
étonnant on va postuler pour être
sélectionneur c'est team américain john
john donaldson l'attention parce
qualifie pour la grande finale sinon il
ya des choix étrange 1 qui sont faits
alors après est-ce qu'il ya eu peut-être
une maladie une demande du joueur ou
quoi c'est aussi possible oui forcément
évidemment dans les équipes dans les
petits papiers mais c'est vrai que les
choix sont sont étonnants pour pour le
moins dire et la composition de l'équipe
d'inde l'inde finalement un petit peu
décevant de fab qui perd un match contre
l'europe hier qu'elle qu'elle tenait en
main et qui se retrouve dernière au
classement
et ouais mais bon sa joie c'est six
matches sur quatre est chic et parti qui
dérape et puis voilà c'était la partie
de d'harmonia qui adhéra intérieur entre
une visite
ouais ça fait ch ap le match et aussi il
y avait 12 da qui était perdant contre
penta l'ami trishna qui avait une
position écrasante et qui a raté duda
donc un match qu'il aura vraiment filer
entre les doigts et à mais attention
quand même à césar 10 1 qui peuvent
éventuellement surprendre la russie sont
les indiens ne sont pas faciles à
manoeuvrer et ouais ben match à lens à
tous les matchs sont assez importants
jeu plus simple donc pour les robes
qu'on va suivre
mais dans ses pieds d'or ce qu'il faut
absolument gagner
ouais alors est ce que est ce qu'il est
si simple ce match franchement quand on
voit sur le papier c'est loin d'être
gagné d'avancé
non mais rien n'est gagné d'avancé mais
si on fait la moyenne au classement elo
entre le joueur dont on peut se dire
chaque joueur européen a plus de
classement alors que son adversaire
c'est simple maxime est mieux classé que
radjabov les bonnes et mieux que la
section déjà à nice dirai mieux placé
que la mine basse m
et pareil donc entre than i télé qui n'a
ainsi pas kassoma a peut-être par rory
sur quatre échiquier bat et puis ça va
être partout enfin c'est ouais ouais
mais après des joueurs extrêmement
dangereux
amine bassem avec les blancs il est
vraiment capable de battre n'importe qui
on l'avait vu lors d'un grand chef tour
ce joueur égyptien
un peu fantasque j'ai envie de dire
capable du meilleur comme du pire mais
mais aussi du meilleur qui peut être
très très dangereux avec les blancs
contre guy ritchie a pas l'air en super
forme
giroud de chasse et c'est le jeune
joueur iranien de 16 ans ou 17 ans je
passais son anniversaire est passé mais
il fait partie du top 20 mondial on va
dire en partie rapide peut-être même top
10 sur internet contre les vannes
aronian c'est loin d'être simple pour
les bons à même si on joue au niveau
d'hier il pourrait il pourrait
l'emporter mais quand même pas si simple
lvl maxime vachier lagrave aux premiers
échiquiers contre radjabov ma foi si
fait nul ce serait un bon résultat et
nanase anisé on est fou quand même
contredit d'arras à tout cas cela
n'avait fait non mais évidemment c'est
pas c'est pas des pins fin mai mais bon
c'est le match qu'il faut ligne kaixi kg
et 2 et 3 c'est là qu'on semble être
plus au dessus je dis rien moi j'en ai
fermé mais les journaux vers cet endroit
mais mais oui bon rien d'évident et
surtout qu'il guérisse important jusqu'à
une baisse elle voit ses joueurs
fantasques qui joue pas trop théorique
il a ses petites bardy et bien les
petites attaques et cette année elle
avec les filles en petite hausse mais ça
peut être dangereux mais c'est sûr de
partir du lot tranchant tu vois il joue
pas avec la la maîtrise souvent de la
partie ait pas nos folles il joue pas
avec le frein à main c'est à dire que
lui voix et lui vaut un virage il freine
pas avant ça les intéresse pas non il te
le prend à la corde il est là quoi
aillent là il a et si jamais été au
coude à coude toute la voiture il a fait
un petit bayrou est un petit coup
d'épaulé soit toi qui sort ce soit moi
enfin ça ne m'intéresse pas pas du tout
intéressés par des petites nul et ça va
faire une opposition de style
intéressante fabien contre guiry qui lui
au contraire toujours en contrôle
toujours solide la biologie on va voir
là une loi qui va ré accéléré mais voilà
très précautionneux pendant
précautionneux ah ouais m'enfin du coup
c'est une belle opposition de styles
tout peut arriver mais serait maroc ce
soit du coup amine ben hassen qui vous
fasse très attention louis contre lui je
ne veux pas me faire contrer eggerickx
je vais je vais jouer la taf on sait
jamais hein parfois et des scénarios
partie assez marrante alors cette
position faible c'est une position ultra
théorique avec un gambien on peut
repasser la partie rapidement parce que
c'est des parties rapides sinon on va
perdre le direct mais à une ouverture
cela donc les noirs qui décide de
soutenir leurs pions des cinq pour tenir
le centre
donc il ya un développement assez
logique ici le couffo f5 pour sortir le
fou devant la structure de pions serez
mauvais à cause de pions vente comprend
et dames b3 avec un problème sur les
pions blancs on va passer rapidement
sinon pour y passer des plombes
mais en tout cas les noirs qui ont le
petit problème du fou mais qu'ils vont
réussir à gagner le pion c4 donc une
position
un petit peu étrange femme en réalité à
la sortie de l'ouverture mais très
théorique oui mais battu joue derrière
toi même souvent ce genre que j'aime
avec les pièces la rue oui et en fait
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est que ballet
national ont gagné un pion par contre
niveau développement
c'est pas facile parce que les fous sont
cependant sortis le roi reste au centre
d'ailleurs le vent pour se poser la
question où est ce qui va se cacher
parce que petit rock compliqué puisqu'on
a déjà poussé monture grand roque la
même chose donc les noirs voire un
problème pour finir développement et à
ce qui a été leur voix à court terme par
contre qui gère bien ce problème là ils
peuvent faire valoir leurs points de
plus à long terme ouais donc avantage
courte d'un court terme pour les blancs
avec l'activité et à un jeu plus plus
facile avantage long terme pour les
noirs avec le pion de plus qu'il ya un
gros pions plus sincère que quand tu
s'il y avait plus les problèmes de
développement gua à 5 des cats et 3 et
le pion passé à il avance me la vente on
exactement là les blancs font l'idée
typique des f4 donc ils ont retiré le
cavalier va lever l'option f4 je peux
montrer en jouant des coudes en passant
le tour aux ténois rang faisant des
allers-retours pour bien montrer l'idée
blanche et mettre une énorme pression
sur le plan des recettes qui serait très
difficile de défendre tallien
complètement d'ailleurs en fait
un petit monde assure encore mieux
prendre de la tour en 24e directement
regard des recettes et en plus ça rend
le foot qui révèrent h4 oui donc je ne
savais plus où j'ai juste pour illustrer
un maire met donc ce pion afssaps et ça
les blancs veulent faire avec 4 et
ouvrir des lignes de toute façon c'est
comme ça qu'il faut jouer quand vous
avez l'ardente âge de développement
parce que c'est un avantage temporaire
ici vous laisser le temps aux autres
adversaires de finalement sortir toutes
ces pièces cet avantage va s'évaporer
donc faut y aller franco compte de ce
type davantage et c'est ce qu'est en
train de faire le jour à zéro et même si
on réussissait
avant je me fais l'écho idiot un pour
les noirs même si on réussissait à faire
mais bon là je fais semblant qu'on peut
pas prendre un coup comme f5 fort serait
quand même ouverture de la colonne
exactement exactement
donc c'est difficile même voire
impossible pour les noirs de deux blocs
et ce alors il fait à mme b 6 et on va
jouer bas de l'autre côté avec les noirs
là où on est le mieux sur le pion des
cats sur le pion de plus et on va
attaquer al elle allaite dame
alors ici a souvent dense position-là
deux manières de continuer soit on fait
quand même f4 et on continue le plan
mais parfois commencé parfois je 5 n'est
pas idiot parce que comme ça sur grand
roque
on pourrait prendre les recettes ouais
mais c'est sûrement très adapté
d'ailleurs le coup de chaud h5 pour
essayer d'aider que le roi part se
cacher oui c'est un coup très typique
dans ses positions est à noter que les
noirs ont beaucoup de mal à mettre la
pression une pression supplémentaire sur
le pion des quatre fans complètement
complètement faudrait avoir le temps de
faire un truc comme qu'avait dbt au
lycée 6 mai perdre encore du temps je
pense pas que ce soit la priorité pour
l'instant tient juste un petit truc on
nous dit dans le chat qui a peut-être
pas la jauge sur le côté alors on va
rajouter la jauge exactement qui permet
de bien visualiser ce que je pense donc
l'ordinateur du jugement de cette
position
et comme on l'avait déjà expliqué on
peut le refaire cette jauge s'adonnent
les vallées son ordinateur tant que ça
reste à peu près centrale comme c'est le
cas en ce moment entre le 4 et le 5 là
par exemple c'est que la position
équilibrée
si les blancs bat beaucoup mieux il y
aura beaucoup de plantes montra très
haut et si c'est les noirs c'est à dire
à jean noir très bas j'ai juste un
indicateur les joueurs bien sûr n'y ont
pas accès mais c'est pour pour le public
pour voir le et savoirs savoir ce qu'il
en est
dans l'ouverture il faut aussi savoir
que tant que ces théories faut pas trop
s'occuper de cette jauge là en tant que
les joueurs suivent la théorie parce
qu'ils ont analysé sur des ordinateurs
extrêmement puissant fabien je peux
arriver parfois dans l'ouverture que
cette jauge s'emballe un petit peu mais
parce que parce que ce sont des analyses
très poussées est très profond de la
part des joueurs qui peuvent mettre à
mal l'évaluation des ordinateurs en
revanche fabien lorsque on arrive en
milieu de jeu ça a beaucoup plus
d'importance que jeter un petit oeil à
cette jauge apparemment là ici par
exemple dans cette partie les joueurs
réfléchissent ça veut dire qu'ils
connaissent probablement plus la théorie
et donc si on voit la jauge s'emballer
ça veut pas dire qu'il ya quelque chose
à faire
cinq femmes et il met la pression sur la
tête du cou est exactement battu l'avait
signalé coûts typiques donc qui t'attend
pêche sont empêchés si énorme que le
vraiment faire grands qui peuvent se
dire bon bah j'avais un film plus
bachelor en sait rien de seagram
mais après ce show est cette attaque rap
du coup si sa se tiendra la nouvelle
cible des blancs avec du talent chez
quatre peut-être des coups comme ça donc
pas l on peut très bien rendre du matin
qu'on avait gagné et qu'on en plus mais
faut s'attendre contre la responsable à
fond enfin vous me tourache cette
histoire de défendre ce pion l'avoir le
temps avec l'europe à partir et à fait
fou et 7
donc elles ont pâti il veut faire du
tour à 8 ou cavaliers fuite qu'elle ait
justice quelque chose comme ça alors la
question qui est en train de poser sa
après avec 4 puis emprunte cas je vais
te montrer une plainte lui poser une
question qui m'est qui me turlupine
pourpre en f4 avec l'idée de prendre f7
est là elle est noire pourrait jouer sur
cette dame est ici c'est le clouage du
pion pour jouer cavalier prend 2,5 c'est
des choses très thématiques mais parfois
gagner ce deuxième pion n'est pas
forcément bon parce que ça ouvre encore
le fou et le roi noir peut se retrouver
complètement en difficulté des pièces
adhère sur sur les fous qui est qu'ils
ont envie à plat lover bas ils ont une
longue portée bien évidemment et
d'ailleurs il vient de jouer à être
quatre fabien alors les noirs peuvent
jouer grand roque aussi éventuellement
et donner du rêve cette maintenant c'est
toujours une option
en revanche je pense que ce qu'on n'a
pas du tout envie de faire fabien c'est
de faire grand
dans un deuxième temps les 130 de la
tour ça je pense que c'est quelque chose
que les noirs ne veulent pas non parce
que c'est pourquoi se fait manger c'est
très bien parce que bien sûr alors la
colonne qu'elle contrôle déjà et en plus
c'est leur inaction horizontal et qui
attaque déjà des pièces qui peut réduire
activités du leroy attaque et peut-être
des pions unsa ya pas trop pu enfin se
fait manger mais très souvent comme cela
on changeait de départ daïna plaint
qu'on peut attaquer et du coup c'est
toujours une bonne opération donc pour
le camp qui arrive à rentrer dans le
camp adverse comme ça sur le septième
rangée donc si maxime décide de donner
ce pion c'est maintenant c'est
maintenant sinon il faudra qu'il arrive
pour la variante part il faut aussi
reprendre du fou mais je pense vraiment
qu'ils déprendre de la tour et de
laisser le jeu puis re 5 1 oui puis un
truc comme peut-être cavale et f3
échangé ce cavalier reprendre de la dame
et puis avec l'idée si le carré départ
du coutal et se venger sur excel et là
fabien juste pour illustrer un avec le
fou en g3 qui rejoint la lorraine même
le le fou cette emprise mais si on se
retrouve avec le fou la tour qui
commence à connecter sur la 7ème ça peut
devenir trop dangereux des armes
pointues des marines en plus on voit ce
roi noir un peu à l'étroit qui peut pas
aller se cacher dans le coin de quoi
donc ça ce sera un énorme danger et est
donc et donc après un pion prend tout
reprend prendre 5 semble centre
dangereux
c'est un gros test 1 pour maxime parce
que ça te rendes de moscou elle est
extrêmement dur à jouer avec les noirs
et mais c'est vrai que lorsqu'on n'a pas
l'habitude ça peut être ça peut aller
très vite
c'est sa part à fait normalement il a vu
bien étudié et c'est une chose de la
voir jouer à l'entraînement et pour le
joueur en partie je peux te dire que
c'est autre chose parce que même un coup
comme regarder ma vie tu fais je parais
si ça on passe le tour même même un tout
comme vous prenez ça ait trois profs
cette dame h5 échec peut se regarder
comment ça marche pas les joueurs paraît
que même ce genre d'idées peut exister
ouais mais ceux qui avaient une partie
maintenant à vaincre à monique comme ça
je pense
autour des années 2000 une partie
qualité qui percevaient peut-être 1
ton à dortmund ou un truc comme ça avec
un sacrifice de pièces avaient été
gagnées par les blancs ne s'était pas
cramique un an plus tôt ben abda fins
certains seront entre les deux en tout
cas je crois que c'était kramnik avec
les blancs mais je suis pas sûr ils ont
tellement joué les deux cette variante
que tu te rappelles plus de week-end
avec les vents le calacs et noir mais
oui partie très connue avec un sac fils
de pièces à ses célèbres
en fait je vois dans l'autre châtre que
s'y attendait déjà deux gagnants contre
contre les goliath chine c'est pas le
match qui nous intéresse sur le coup ce
match entre l'inde et la russie
mais du temps 15 coups pourri challandes
après on peut peut-être juste jeter un
oeil si c'est déjà gagnant gagnant doit
se faire mater et maxime qui a fait
grand cas il va laisser le pion à vii
est à mon avis la raison donc c'est très
rare quand ça arrive ça a au niveau une
victoire expéditive comme ça on l'a dit
les joueurs castrais bien leur ouverture
peut-être que vishy anand avait préparé
quelque chose en réserve ou simplement
diane despaux minatchy a oublié a
confondu fait avoir cette partie qui est
déjà finie on va la passer rapidement
parce que c'est vrai que c'est rare une
partie gagnée en 13 minutes même pas dix
minutes par l'affiché annonce c'était
une ruine freine de fabien ouverture
fétiche du joueur russe
exactement et en plus lente que
nepomniachi avait déjà eu à affronter au
candidat exactement cette vente la con
tre anish giri n'est ce pas oui et j'en
avais déjà bon commenté ensemble je
pense en direct et donc vichy qui a
préparé quelque chose en réserve
vous avez mon exposition après des cas
de quoi changer les fous il est son fond
prises et il avance à fond pour aller
occuper les cases noires est rentré que
saddam les motels roide expéditive et ya
rien à faire donc bravo michel lalande
qui s'y rapportent sont première
victoire en oui c'est choquant du monde
et qui envoie son équipe d'un bien sûr
sur de très bons rails
et attention attention à l'équipe à
l'équipe russe 1 parce qu une glissade
contre nantes pourrait faire vraiment
très mal un au classement tu peux
remettre un petit coup de classement
pour bien voir où nous en sommes mais tu
peux avoir que la russie est quand même
un petit peu détaché dans le wagon usa
europe et en russie
c'est allé dans le bon wagon cette
équipe de russie mais en cas de défaite
sont déjà un petit peu derrière et
l'europe et les états unis pourraient
pourrait s'envoler ça pourrait faire un
championnat à trois exactement
exactement virus c'est pas la bonne
opération de deux cartons pleins
d'aujourd'hui qui est dernier du
classement
complètement ce serait c'est ce serait
une mauvaise opération même un match nul
serait mauvaise opération d'ailleurs ils
sont ils sont un petit peu distancé et
c'est pas le moment de laisser des
points en route
alors rajab office il réfléchit à quoi
ils se demandaient ce que je prend
directement à vii où est ce que je
prends en premier angers 5-1 ce qui
semble intéressant et vous rendant but
avec la tour burj imaginer ce qu'on
redonne tout à l'heure en fait une
tourbière placé par la voix et qui
imaginent que la voir une critique c'est
fou ou trois échecs par la suite fut f2
pour défendre le pion à un garde fou
prend f2 est peut-être la tour qui doit
acquitter sur wyclef 2 pourrait jouer
sur un clouage il ya toujours le fameux
calais prenait 5 1 et là par contre la
tour prend et tu sais ça ressemble
beaucoup à une structure de française du
coup et ben moi je préfère les blancs y
siens et ouais mais bon on aura toujours
quand même avec les noirs notre contre
chance dans toutes les finales avec un
pion des captures en c3 qui pourront
avancer et ça reste compliqué mais le
plan blanc est assez simple cavalière
froid dam des deux tours à f1 et on
rentre sur la colonne f
après tu avais gagné le pion l'abordage
6 après fabien c'est une ouverture que
je joue exclusivement avec les noirs
mais je veux que cette variante là
contre des quatre depuis que j'ai que
j'ai 10 ans ça fait 23 ans que je joue
ça je peux te dire que c'est une
souffrance c'est une souffrance
j'ai eu l'occasion de parler de cette
variante avec d'excellents 2001 elle son
frère de dinara et alexander great
choqué je lui ai dit je joue seulement
depuis toute ma vie je comprends pas
pourquoi jouer avec les noirs il m'avait
répondu moi non plus oui
non mais je sais pas plus
est-ce que c'était à l'époque où dingli
rennes l'utiliser également dans les
candidats précédents de berlin 2018
enfin je crois
pratique pour le jouer moi bref c'est
vrai que la réponse on m'a amusé moi non
plus mais c'est vrai que c'est jamais
facile pour les noirs c'est énorme il
faut connaître une tonne de théorie et
sans rappeler pour réussir à égaliser et
si tu trébuche à un moment donné tu es
moins bien et même si tu réussis à bien
récité la théorie c'est même pas c'est
même pas fait encore mais c'est une
ouverture qui qui donne l'avantagé
j'ai gagné beaucoup de parties avec je
dois dire avec les noirs parce que un
niveau peut-être un peu moins moins fort
que radjabov et maxime vachier lagrave
les joueurs peuvent être un peu
déstabilisé avec les blancs parce que
c'est les positions à triple tranchant
passé très sauvage très vite avec des
échanges réciproques et donc donc les
blancs parfois il est joueur qui aime
bien justifiée dans un petit avantage
tranquille et maîtrisé la partie
il a en fait foi les dans le vif du
sujet très vite parce que tu as déjà un
ton moins donc si tu te la joues pépère
battus à perdre quoi donc ça peut ne pas
convenir à certains types de joueurs
être une très bonne arme comme ça oui
oui c'est vraiment étrange quand tu
joues ses positions avec les noirs tu te
sens pas forcément très bien parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de possibilités pour les
blancs les adversaires réfléchissez un
peu longtemps
tous quatre notre niveau parce que il ya
beaucoup de choses qui semblent
intéressantes et puis tout d'un coup en
l'espace de 2-3 coup les blancs n'ont
plus aucun jeu et les noirs se
retrouvent mieux c'est un scénario que
j'ai souvent vécu et c'est un genre de
magie de la variante on va dire
l'impression que c'est dur et puis tout
d'un coup c'est moi votre prévu c'est
vrai dire que prévu mais c'est comme tu
le disais il ya ceux contre jeu qui tout
d'un coup partir un des 4 à 5 le fou qui
y en a 6 et tout d'un coup
ben justement c'est un peu une épée de
damoclès au-dessus de la tête des blancs
ça de choisir un bon françois dugas face
aux pions je ne peux pas faire ce que je
veux enlever toutes les pièces de
l'autre côté et à y voilà et donc voilà
radjabov donc avec les blancs qui m
les c2 donc bien contre la case 2 3 et
défendre ce en tuant des cartes qui n'a
donc pas pris le pion à vii pour
l'instant qu'ils imaginent prendre le
coup d'après ben s'ils l'attaquent deux
fois qui est défendue 0 par contre
maxime s'il veut le sauver que l'avancée
du goût d'une ou deux cases ça devrait
revenir aux mêmes devraient avoir au
pire une prise en passant quand un plus
un réseau de cases on peut le prendre au
coup d'après en passant comme s'ils
allaient d'avancé que d'une les
reprendre du fou peut-être pour remettre
la pression sur le pion des 4 art
compliqué les noirs auraient un pion
plus mais comme on le disait ce roi un
peu en danger dans les cordes
et puis maintenant du coup ce serait
l'option aussi sa nouvelle targets des
blancs le fourrage 5.0 ce clergé gatl à
petit tour en le vin on voit ton près
d'une sorte de translation et on s'en
prendre à une nouvelle cible donc
peut-être un peu comme roy h1 sont
allées du riz en berne
et puis ensuite donc commencer jobs qui
fait qu et blanc et donc radjabov qui
reste donc dans cette optique de gambeat
donc de jouer camions de moins mais avec
de l'activité impactant les organismes
une autre idée pour être de jouer avec à
4 ha
avec une double idée m'ont déjà sans
prendre option b 5 on pose une question
si les noirs protège on pourra
éventuellement échanger et sans arrêt à
voir cette tour sur la colonne à quoi le
nouvelle équipe est extrêmement
dangereuse on pourrait même imaginer un
plan fabien de fou un fou à 5 pour bien
vous êtes heureux de doubler et toi ton
rêve trois tours à 3 plein de choses en
fait qu'il pourrait arriver tout d'un
coup parce que l'ouverture cette colonne
va forcément benizio lens ils ont déjà
les tours qui ont accès et noir loin de
là et en plus avec le fou c'est vrai que
s'il a tout arrive ça peut faire mal et
si les noirs poussant b4 tus pour monter
ses des plans très typique pour le pion
qui avance en bep cap ou regarder la
colonne fermé on pourrait jouer un coup
comme à cinq et on poserait la question
à la dame c'est à dire tu dois protéger
et b4 et ce pion de 6 donc c'est une une
idée qui peut permettre aux blancs de
rajouter une cible est encore plus
d'affaiblir le kg ont eu si ça peut
jouer de concert avec le tour a infligé
quatre dont tu parles est un petit peu
plus tôt fabien exactement mais nous
commençons une bonne et des squats la
patrie alors il a joué f5 maxime le
programme cissé il a repris du cavalier
du coup d'accord donc pas du fou pas
peut-être pourquoi pas parce que ça pose
une question donc au chômage 5 et ce
cavalier qui est à bloquer pacifiquement
un temps aussi revenir vers un pataquès
de quatre centrales est toujours très
bien placé et messieurs c'est vrai que
ces positions peuvent contenir à maxime
ans et qu'il est très fort en tactique
c'est un joueur qui calcule très bien et
là le truc c'est qu'il est un pion plus
qu'un alors même si la position est
difficile si domine son adversaire en
calcul dans le jeu compliqué et par la
finale se gagnera simplement
donc c'est peut-être là qu'on peut
comprendre le choix de variantes de
maxime qui peut se révéler redoutable
mais il adore un complice maxime équipe
et un matérialiste enfin c'est assez
étonnant parce qu'il adore on donnait
enfin celle dérange pas d'en donner pour
trouver de l'activité voire des pièces
qui joue 3 2 contre jeu messi peut en
prendre un qui voit pas de problème
concret immédiat il va toujours actuel
5e bien joué avec l'activité mais qui
aime bien aussi jouer contre l'activité
non en fait dès que c'est compliqué
qu'il faut calculer il est à son aise
bien sûr aux échecs il faut tout en
calculer mais il ya des positions qui
s'y prêtent plus
par exemple celle contrairement donc
quand le jeu est très bloqués ou c'est
plus un jeu de manoeuvre ou mal tant il
n'y a pas de clash direct et on doit
penser comment améliorer sa position ou
bien passer les pièces quelles pièces
échangées donc ça c'est plus le jeu
stratégique et maxime mora évidemment il
sait faire un lit qui n'est pas le top 5
mondial pour rien mais il est tout le
temps de toute façon plus à l'aise quand
c'est du calcul brut comme ça et et de
la tactique qui pourrait être
intéressant enfin bien pour les blancs
peut-être c'est le ku'damm 2 avec l'idée
de se mettre en batterie d'utiliser
cette case e5 laissée vacante par le
sacrifice de pions et tantes et
peut-être de s'infiltrer jusqu'en b8
avec la dame
ouais complètement complète dans une
très bonne idée ça serait ça serait
jouable et alors qu'est ce qui se passe
6 et 9 ans tout comme cavalier e 4 à ce
moment là justement pour bloquer la dame
qu'il n'aura pas accès simple maintenant
voilà pas soit changée ce fou qui est
très fort on vous le gardez avec les
blancs parce qu'elle a une diagonale
ouverte et ça se voit il contrôle plein
de cases donc c'est pas un coup on voit
ça a changé côté blanc et bas combat
continue ça peut être la suite de la
partie ce serait une suite assez logique
je pense pas que les noirs aient envie
de d'aller prendre le poil 5 bizarrement
parce que ce cavalier me semble vraiment
primordiale un e 4 il est extrêmement
fort oui mais en fait c'est un peu font
débat c'est pas si mal le prendre ce
flou mais vu qu'en fait les noirs de
manière générale leurs faiblesses et les
cases noires puisqu'ils ont tous les
pions sans casse blanche ils sont fixés
sur quatre manches ils peuvent pas
bouger vraiment donc en fait ces cases
noires sont faibles il ce cavalier c'est
une des pièces qui peut tenir les cases
noires mais je vois là donc il choisit
il a c'est ça les 25 alliés un fou c'est
qu'un flou en fait il est bloqué sur une
couleur donc s'en fait
il sera très utile sur le jeu sur ces
gens de couleur par contre pour à
maintenir intervenir sur l'autre moitié
de l'échiquier est donc là le
on va dire le conflit a l'air d'être un
attrait important sur case noire est
donc donné ce cavalier contrat foot case
manche qui n'intervient pas dans ce
conflit là c'était pas l'idée du siècle
même si ça va pas être non plus kata
kata mais ça a l'air d'être plus malin
de l'utiliser différemment h4 il élargit
encore le conflit il y avait aussi dans
les coups possibles à 1 toujours à 4-1
ce couac a donc on a parlé un peu plus
tôt
s'il est possible à chaque à chaque tour
on pourrait jouer avec les blancs pour
provoquer quelque chose elle est la
joueuse 4 encore un autre conflit alors
je n'ai pas pensé à ce coup mais à vrai
dire ça que s'appelle rio parce que le
fou fou la case parcours bond et noir
vont sûrement joué le coup intermédiaire
cavaliers eu 4 ou qu'elle ébranle son
arc avec 4 il apte à créer le fou j'ai 3
mai aurait peut-être fou et cinq ici
fabien qui viennent gagner la tour four
en h4 fou prend ensuite éventuellement
tour m mais l'ordre auraient deux pions
pour la qualité et se serait débarrassé
du foot gaz voire des blancs qui font de
très très très peur sur cette diagonale
et ça pourrait peut-être pas que c'est
passé pour les arts se signale alors
après ça assez effrayant parce que la
tourte wario f7 et la dame angers7
et maintenant on a un autre problème
c'est que comme les blancs ont deux
tours et qu'on en a plus qu'une avec les
noirs on peut être très faible sur les
colonnes et les ranger et du coup ce
déséquilibre matériel la poserait
d'autres problèmes mais mais les noirs
auraient toujours l'avantagent matériel
1 2 pions et 1 et un cavalier ou un fou
son plus fort qu'une tour a minima de
l'eau mais normalement at il voulu faire
trois ans les cotes maximales jeu qui
avait lieu 4 et maintenant gars radjabov
de montrer ce qu'il accable pg rinke
fouet 5 c'est une poule qui va jouer
c'est par le plus logique de tous pour
attaquer plusieurs choses pierre latour
et le fou après est-ce qu'il va très mal
et prendre la qualité où il dit bon et
je me donne encore ce pion qui n'est pas
ce qui intéresse en jeu peu de choses je
sais pas oui peut aussi commencer par
dams et 4 1 et garder les tout le monde
sous pression est donc peut-être juste
un petit coup de fouet et cinq îles de
pression peut-être pourrait prendre
cette tour mais devront peut-être qu'à
vrai dire il compte juste se faire un
tour et cette fois c est peut-être we
fight leur bonne chose mais je veux dire
vous
garder pour le 5 tours fc est allé là
bas c'est très complexe mais voir des
variantes vraiment à regarder cette
fosse est tueur de saint martin pour
prendre cette dame jessen branche les
dingos comme ça pour arriver dans la
partie comme ça voilà ça pourrait être
une vente voilà ok voilà bon on est
complètement en train de faire des longs
champs et comet
ouais mais ça peut arriver bien sûr et
souvent vos chèques c'est comme ça on va
trouver calculé essayer de prévoir un
peu aussi que ce patient cet art là pour
une autre est également choisir ce qui
nous arrange de plus quand on un jour
mais oui donc ce coup de fouet aux 5 et
oui ce que je voulais dire aussi
d'autres sections fou prend h4 on peut
aussi les clients deux pas du tout
vouloir rayer la qualité mais juste pour
trois dates et commencer les menaces par
là bas alors les loger quatre avant des
normes pourrait du coup sacrifier la
dame mais là encore il aurait damas ils
auraient fou tour deux pions contre une
dame et c'est encore les noirs qui
serait mieux matériellement donc c'est
marrant hein finalement comme ils ont
deux pions plus fin il pourra vendre
d'options plus un après après c'est
cette supra h4 ils peuvent se permettre
de rendre même pas mal de matériel est
resté est resté devant matériellement et
c'est un des dangers aussi de cette
variante pour les blancs c'est qu'on
peut dire ouais mais là j'ai des ventes
où je récupère du matériel et finalement
on a tellement donné que cette zone
c'est pas ton de sol c'est comme si tu
investis 10000euros vie tu vois un truc
qui vient c'est mieux pour gagner les
huiles mais en tête à moins de 1000 à la
fin un petit peu ça samedi il faut viser
goukoye s'est aussi dit minh tu vises 15
nov
il avait investi milles avec un pion
déjà investi 2000 avec un deuxième pion
il va falloir qu'il va fort qui gagne le
gros en tout cas il réfléchit et ça
c'est plutôt bon signe pour maxime parce
qu'après h4 normalement carioca tu étais
le coup le plus logique
fabien dont il brigue qui vérifie ses
calculs qui se rend compte qu'il a
oublié un truc dans une des variantes
moi je parle tu partirais plutôt sur un
loupé lien ouais ouais ouais c'est long
quand même pas ce cash 4
ayew 4 c'était vraiment dû voir l'heure
avec que des proches et peut-être qu'il
a raté karen young à toi mais ça arrive
comme ça parce que non mais peut-être
qu'il a juste regarder fou ou 5 fu h4
reprend ensuite 3 suisses exigent d une
qualité c'est rien et que maintenant il
se rend compte que les noirs ont quand
même deux pions pour la qualité que que
les noirs ont peut-être un fou qui va
venir en g3 et j'en sais rien ça ça
semble dangereux s'il me d'hécatombe
il y aurait quand même toutes les pièces
noires à la tacle pas peut-être qu'il
s'est dit ah ouais voilà je fais fouet 5
c'est pas possible et il se rend compte
que maintenant en fait c'était possible
a pris 3 minutes 40 quand même un bon
jouer h4 et il a repris 3 minutes 40
pour je fous aux cinq sauvetages trop de
40 par coup ouais 3,40 et 6 6/10 et 3000
quinté 3/10 il a le feu n'a atteint
qu'un peu plus rapidement il accélère il
change de gommes lisses mans aurait tout
changé il faut cinq heures maximum par
manon franche 4 séparé comme le plus
logique un oui disons que l'autre option
serait fou aux 7
oui mais pourquoi pas prendre ce option
va te sont reconnaissants maxi monde isa
il aime bien de prendre les pions s'il
voit rien de concret en plus un petit
reportage très étonné qu'ils ne le
prennent pas faudrait qu'ils aient peur
d'un truc avec d'amal dame g4 pour ne
pas le prendre
guillaume concrètes il faster on va voir
fabien téléphone qui sonne je vais dans
mon rêve à l'étang jolie soirée
téléphone une jolie sonneries de
téléphone chez fabien du coup le fou qui
arrive en veut 5 qui attaquent la
tourache 8
on va voir comment les noirs continuent
en tout cas maxime qui réfléchit on voit
voix l'antenne il a un petit peu fatigué
car il a pas l'air d'être dans la
meilleure forme
je sais par ye done it done fait des
petits sites lassitude après ça fait
longtemps qu'ils jouent assez deuxième
tournoi qu'il enchaîne
de terminer le manuscrit nationale
vendredi dernier il enchaîne avec ce
tournoi depuis mardi ça fait beaucoup de
partis et maxime qui a pas l'air d'être
dans la meilleure forme
je sais pas je le sens un peu fatigué à
la caméra regardent ils se croient que
les yeux là elle se frotte les yeux
bleus mais oui ou non mais regarde je
sens je me sens pas mieux tu as i paris
iii que les yeux et la peau dure et des
biens immobiliers toute l'année il peut
pas même ouais mais bon il que faisait
il enchaîne les tournois il enchaîne les
compétitions et bien finir le magnus
invitationnal savaient qu'ils ont des
risques de flou il pourrait essayer de
trouver des calendriers un peu plus
tranquille où les joueurs pas que c'est
peut-être les conditions parce que c'est
évidemment c'est pas comme quoi un tour
de france et faire des centaines de
kilomètres chaque jour mais d'être
concentré plusieurs heures par jour à un
moment tu été crevés pas même double
fatigué mais c'est comme on va dire
quand il ya des partielles pour les gens
qui vont à la fac où les examens sont
afida semaines d'examen à la fin vous
tenez des propos que ça s'arrête un peu
si tu veux ça pendant trois semaines
d'affilée un mois dur ça va bien se
passer
maxime qui est réfléchie et coûteux les
deux joueurs qui sont rentrés dans cette
vente ultra complexes sur un peu au
feeling allez touche sa souris là j'ai
l'impression
il va prendre le pion h4 ils vont être
en train de calculer les dames g4 et
compagnie on va voir comment il réagit
alors peut-être faire un tout petit tour
très rapide un fabien sur les autres
alors les jeunes est guéri et où sa voix
juste un peu regardé la jauge pour se
faire un avis alors c'est quoi ça il a
les blancs les bonnes blagues qui breda
mission compliquée l'ordinateur la jauge
un petit peuvent en faveur des blancs
ouais je pense que nul probant points
oui le docteur amine passe m
et on a une position très compliqué
comme prévu peu comme prévu et
et ouais je sais pas partout alors pour
l'instant matériellement c'est égal mais
les blancs ils ont une tour attaqué mais
peut aller prendre un pion et quand même
donner une qualité à je ne sais pas
c'est juste juste très très chaud
position bouillante sur ont peut-être
même une des plus intéressantes du match
avec celle de maxime à l'est dans
l'évolution vraiment très indécise et et
ici dinara ça doit castorama avec les
noix donc l'ajout du reste du monde
contre nana hines est là je vous amène
ses expressions blanche quand même un
petit prêt sur deux mange ce soir là on
a quand même ce conflit là qui est enfin
cette cette colonne pour le moment à
nous et peut-être des peu sain qu'un
jour on peut pas jouer tomber vite c'est
évident qu'il ya eu 5 mélo tour sur un
possible jusqu'à la catastrophe attaque
le roi avec le fou et le roi peut pas se
rapprocher vous pascal latour coupe et
ça paiera donc se fout ce chemin mais
s'avère très solide quand même alors
bien sûr ça peut se gagner partie long
courrier on est mais en tout cas les
noirs les noirs assez solide et qui vont
sûrement essayer d'échanger toutes ces
tours sur la colonne c'est audard et se
diront bah voila j'ai passé le plus dur
j'aurais tout comme roy 17 pour partir
de tout jeunes vers un tour assez sains
et on ramène et voilà et si toutes les
tours sans même les noirs peut avoir
l'espoir un jour de gagner parce qu'ils
ont surtout contre un allèle dame
donc ils vont avancer les pions et
l'inscription basse et les blancs vont
amener leurs pièces un peu pour
justement et exception avec trop loin et
ça pour laisser le champ libre au noir
votre côté alors ça c'est très long
terme
mais c'est pas inimaginable comme
scénario alors on va retourner sur la
partie de maxime vachier lagrave où il
ya eu la prise en h4 on va revenir au
moment où en était le pion h4 qui a été
pris la dame comme prévu qui est venu
angers 4 et le fou qui est revenue
angers 5
on en est là fabien et a maintenant est
ce que les blancs vont s'emparer de la
tourache 8 ou est ce qu'ils vont essayer
de faire fuir cette d'abord pour jouer
un petit peu sur le roi parce que vous
prendrez si sûr
himat si fabien casillas du quasi
complètement 57 c'est très intéressant
et l'autre coup qui a l'air intéressant
c'est tout rires ça tout bon mais est ce
que le gain de cette dame serait si
c'est intéressant c'est une autre
question
non mais tu gardes tout taux de change
fait que jouer pour iliad a toujours
gagné la qualité tu peux toujours prêt à
tenir bon que je vais gagner le pion
aussi ça mais il faut en fait j'aime
bien en fait plusieurs coups très
tentant et je pense c'est un coût qui
vaudra cher parce que cette tradition
très importante pour la suite de la
partie est très clairement à fabien
c'est une décision qui pourrait valoir
son pesant d'or
côté côté blanc mais une partie qui peut
tourner des deux côtés qui peut tourner
faveur de maxime faveur de deux teams ou
rouen match nul là vraiment rien n'est
fait dans cette partie et aussi bien
évidemment le fou prend elle je suis
teint qui est toujours envisageable
bleus ne sont pas du tout me reprocher
il faut avancer à 3,17 c'est vraiment
une ligne critique
alors comment ça peut continuer ici tour
achevé 8,1 du coup mais moi oui mais là
il aurait prise et tous rêvent c'est pas
mal alors à temps il a joué et bien
l'avouer tout rêve 7 alors tour à ce g8
sa part être le coup logique pour
essayer de se venger sur l'autre dame
exactement préparé une découverte donc
enlever ce chou parce qu'en fait la dame
blanche est exposée par rapport à la
tour il ya que le fou noir au milieu et
noir pour l enlever donc sur la case de
trois ans faisant échec au passage cinq
noms du coup tour ses sept pour être
joués dame france et cette france s est
il faudra regarder maintenant foule
trois échecs le cavalier s'emparait du
fou latour mangent les annales
le fou mangent les la tour c'est une
langue quasiment forcé ballon des deux
mains comble à l'étranger 3 vous l'avez
un tour j'ai trois double attaque
cavaliers f1 contre attaque roi prend
des huit prend une pièce cavaliers
proche des trois quarts à l'étranger 3
et le fou quelque part et il faudrait
évaluer ça alors les plans ou quoi foot
hourcadet plus content d'options qui
ronge mais le fou blanc est meilleur que
l'autre parce que tous les pions sont
sur blanc alors vas savoir ça qu'ici
c'est vraiment mieux gagnant pour les
blancs moi je sais pas bah le prologue
je pense c'est surtout culture h est
faible il rêve de tour h1 ça va arriver
et si on perd ce pion h c'est ça le
drame
en fait tu aurais pas le plonger et h je
croise la salle et déclarent inquiets
mais là ça peut être en studio qui est
dingue c'est peut-être oui alors après
l'autre option aussi évidemment sentence
et 7 c'est de savoir donc ça donne quoi
ça c'est fou tour de pions contre dame
enfin deux pions un point bas devrait
reprendre au 6 mai c'est pas clair du
tout
je préfère les blancs ici c'est à dire
mais bon c'est peut-être juste visuel et
at on va se cacher rappeler 3,8 là bas
j'ai fait un tour en sécurité mais
j'aime pas surexposer ils tuent voit
l'importance d'avoir introduit un truc
comme a4 a6 on en parlait tout à l'heure
face à la vue d'une des six autres
années mais aurait dû à cinq dames pays
6 ou du pion prend puis on prend et tour
à cinq toiles et ses cd petite nuance
qui parfois peuvent changer beaucoup
mais cependant à carte était une menace
c'est compliqué alors il ya vu tour à j
8 1 maxime là je pense que tout ça ça
doit être jouée à moins qu radjabov
décide de retirer la saddam de cette
colonne
mais je pense qu'il ya des entorses à
cette aussi mais un bout que date damage
3 ou quoi gardant un peu les options ça
peut être un fils il a faim c'est moi
qui pouvais ouais ça peut être une
option parce que bon on se met en face
d'eux on s'enlève justement du vis-à-vis
avec la tour et on garde le pion lot 6
en ligne de mire en gare de tours c'est
cette possible mais plein de choses
c'était un coup qui va joueur a d'abord
je sais pas peut reporter le conflit la
douane à mach iii est justement aux
portes de conflit un petit peu plus tard
les trucs très concret savoir sk france
de garder toutes ses options il va pas
ne plus en avoir ce que tu t'es leurs
bijoux ça pourrit tout ces options que
tous ces options mais bon le jour des
jeux ne seront plus à tour regarde y'a
plus la qualité le plus à l'heure il n'y
a plus la table basse et voit pas ces
options il les a gardés ça s'est fait
une belle jambe
bon bah vous êtes sûrs culte à tour pour
gagner toutes les options comme un nom
mais maintenant il doit partir pour fou
j'ai 4.97 sa réunir maintenant faut
prendre cette forêt fuite et c'est cette
position qui va arriver sur l'échiquier
va savoir à quel point je donne tout ce
qu'il ya des victoires en f1 et
maintenant ce fou peut-être revenir
ensuite c'est hyper compliqué c'est
compliqué mais écoute ça a pas l'air
trop mal se passer pour maxime ce qu'ils
avaient dit un cadre très fort bien
ancrée on ne touche pas le fou g5 pareil
ils contrôlent pas mal de cases le roi
il est pas trop en danger parce que je
m'en fous j'ai 5
pour bien des grenades etc saha baird à
ordonné
c'est extrêmement compliqué après tour
f1 aussi une option a d'ailleurs mais là
mais bon rappelons-le a vu que maxime a
pris d'options vous faudra quand même
que les blancs un moment montrent un
petit peu quelque chose mais sinon ça se
payer à la fin pour f1 garde toutes les
options ça vient exactement l'option fou
g46 garde l'option à tour prend 17 ils
gardent les gardes les options tais toi
et tous les petits mitrons de ses peurs
oui et puis ça ramène la dernière pièce
en jeu puisque c'est la dernière pièce
blanche qui ne joue pas je serai ce
serait à ce serait le plus logique en
fait - ouais l'ordinateur qui préfèrent
un peu les noirs mais mme émond la
pollution est tellement complexe je suis
même pas sûr que dans notre notre module
soit assez fort pour voir tous les
tenants et les aboutissants il ya
énormément d'options pour les deux
joueurs mais a fait tour à une fin il
garde toutes ses options fallait un
rayon mode de garde et les options mais
c'est vrai qu'à un moment toute façon il
faudra de concret il faudrait qu'il soit
compris comme ça justement c'est le
genre de partie où tu peux pas juste
jouer des coups bien en général il faut
vraiment aller calculé concrètement
qu'est ce que ça donne les variantes et
tous à rejeter juste un petit tailleur
faire un tour des stades
donc les jeunes qui jouent contre un
pion isolés sont des cinq qui l'isolé
pourquoi s'il a plu turon pour le
défendre
mais c'est dur d'attaquer quand enfin il
va essayer il un bon rapport à terrier
le tour mais je trouve que les noirs
dont quand même de bonnes chances aussi
d'égaliser un scénario qui peut être
éventuellement possible un jour derrière
faire [ __ ] aux cavaliers les blancs
vont amener toutes leurs grosses pièces
pour gagner le pion il gagnait mais les
noirs échange et on va finir une finale
deux tours 4 contre 3 sur la même
un brando reprend cette aventure prend
bel et blanc aimerait bien en reprenant
prompte de tête du pion mais année ton
tour tu remportes remportant la tour
s'en va et ensuite ça s'est passé un
petit nul les normes être leurs pions h
7 h 5
il n'y a pas trop mal moyen de passer
comme message que j'ai les miens parfois
tout temps en temps ça en rapide c'est
quand même assez sain par un fab
mais je pense que votre tentative de
défense de par des noirs de faire jour
truc manière la plus logique mais il
faudra réussir le jeune joueur iranien
qui a pas toujours été impérial en
finale contre un renard comme comme les
bonnes moi je demande à voir la défense
dans 7 4 contre 3 elle n'est peut-être
pas si simple et le nom depuis le début
du tournoi qui joue y perdre
oui il m'a dit eh bien on joue vite et
bien et c'est ce qu'il faut qu il a 16
minutes 34 entre deux minutes trente
moi je mettrais une pièce sur les bonnes
ici même celle d'un homme on a
clairement il ya des chances de
l'emporter dans cette partie alors le
docteur amine pacem contre anish giri
c'est le bordel y'a pas c'est quoi ce
blanc donc cet ordre en cavale et qui va
arriver
il a donc le son le docteur il vraiment
docteur tout ça mais en fait je connais
pas mal je voudrais en deux équipes soit
à clichy en france ou dans mon équipe en
bundesliga
il est en plus il est sympa mais away il
a fait des études et tout y est c'est
quelqu'un d'assez brillant parce qu'il
ya rentrer dans lesdites mondiale aux
échecs on contient des études à côté ce
qui est pas le cas de tout le monde qui
est quasiment le cas de personne
d'ailleurs
le dernier échiquier alors attends on
n'a plus la position actuelle on va voir
ce qui s'est passé est un peu de
pression le long de la colonne des
voiles a quand même réussi un petit
quelque chose avec les blancs elle
réussit à mettre la pression le long de
cette colonne b et elle menace peut-être
tour c'est un leroy qui pourrait
peut-être partir gagner plus on b6 dans
certaines variantes on ne sait pas non
ça c'est un peu plus avoir pour les
blancs et elle a gardé les tours
d'ailleurs elle n'est pas de tout
rentrait non scénario dont on parlait
tout à l'heure avec les changes massives
des tours qui favoriserait grandement
les noirs et elle essaye donc je pense
que pour les noirs sera toujours
possible de défendre mais c'est pas tout
simple et puis il ya moins de dix
minutes à la pendule maintenant et ça
peut ne peut pas bien se passer pour
pour la joueuse kazakh
alors après tout la f1 dans la partie de
maximy maxime vient de grues fouet cette
photo karine vanasse kg 5
mais pourquoi enfin safran alors c'est
quoi le coup qu'il ya toutes les options
mais je sens qu'il appuie trop d'options
avec les plans du coup toutes les garder
s'il y en a plus non mais il a trop
voulu éviter peut-être le jeu qu'on perd
c'est oui mais le problème en fait c'est
une hausse non tu appelles ça aille plus
en plus il avait que des bonnes options
entre guillemets avec les blancs femme
qui gagnera jamais je veux dire il avait
il avait que des options qui donnait un
truc plus ou moins bien et c'est sa
force ne rien vouloir faire battu fait
contrer ces qualités là comme pour
d'autres les aronian et heavy roja
grosse avance à la pendue pour maxime
qui a onze minutes contre 3 et
il pourrait s'imposer maxime leeuwen
enfin en fait les teams europe pourrait
faire un gros score par anish pour un
petit peu en sueur à cette partie mais
encore rien n'est fait c'est compliqué
mais trois autres joueurs de la team
europe semble maîtriser leur sujet et
pousse dans ses positions
ouais après faut faire attention quand
même parce que c'est pas c'est tous des
positions justement qu utiliser il n'y a
pas de contrôle pour le moment c'est des
positions qui peuvent vite tourner un
celle de maxime notamment et surtout
cette gamine basse mo3 aussi qui
pourrait tourner rapidement en faveur du
joueur égyptien
attention attention quand même c on est
plutôt favoris mais
mais il n'y a pas de stabilité encore
les positions ne sont pas figés dans le
marbre
évidemment pas gagnant c'est juste comme
un confortable va vraiment falloir
s'appliquer et pas faire la même erreur
que lundi hier contre nous qui a laissé
le socialement filer le match
surtout que là c'est un match vraiment
primordial 1 pour l'équipe européenne
qui pourrait remonter surtout si ça se
passe mal pour les russes et je sais pas
comment ça se passe côté américain
contre de la gym du coach peut être te
fais un petit pont de tâches de mon côté
juste voir qu'est ce qui se passe côté
américain alors de la ligue 1 contre
view sage ou alors il y aura tenu la
route
voilà exactement et tous les autres
partis jouent voilà jeu et côté inde
russie à une nulle de karuïa keane
contre a dit ban donc il ne reste plus
que deux parties aux russes pour pour
remonter leurs déficits alors que steam
ou rajabi vient de mettre sa tour en h7
et il est ce qu'un manager 5 mai à alger
de prendre et contre cloud pour faire un
contrecoup l'orage exactement et
attaquer peut-être l'option achetez donc
des trucs que kg 5 pour vraiment le
faire de quoi peut-être pas alors
qu'attend on nous dit on nous dit que
dirige serait serez perdants
j'aimerais bien quand même faire un
passage de l'ariège peut-être une chute
de geri on va voir si cette information
est juste bon perdant il est moins bien
il est moins bien mais perdant ça reste
un très grand mot il encore ses chances
de de la soul il peut tout donner
allez on retourne sur maxime après ce
tour h7 la position alors il veut se dit
veut simplement fou fc atteint pour
expliquer le coup que vient de jouer à
timour pour venir mettre la pression sur
ce point ici c'est mettre la pression
nommé regarde bien les options garde
pour prendre le stis il garde fou est
peut-être il ya tout un ff7 donc il est
toujours à la limite ça je suis encore
en contrôle j'ai beaucoup d'options
bon le ska madness et 2 est bien placé
aussi camille défend bien le pion des
cats qui est son point faible il
contrôle
akkas de 3 si jamais ces pièces sont pas
mal placée avec avec les blancs mais bon
il ya deux pions de retard donc c'est
cher le placement de pièces
fabien mais c'est que ça après ce cas il
peut juste venir angers 5 pour venir
angers 5
ils contrôlent à vii mais il est là il
contrôle le 6 mai finalement fait vii
tours fc est c'était deux idées bon ben
c'est de venir sur excel toi donc on
contrôle on attaque tas d'amis d'amis g3
d'accord et puis peut-être il faut faire
quelque chose pour pour sortir de ce
quoi je sais pas exactement comment et
continuer ça peut ça peut clairement
être une option pour au maximum pour
maxime et l'homme en fait c'est une
partie justement compliqué parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de coups qui semble
intéressant et plus ou moins mêmes
valeurs et c'est juste pas simple du
tout du contraire
l'ardéchois il a fait qu'avaliser 5
pédagogie quatre tables g3 été une autre
option 2004 aussi complètement jouable
bien évidemment policiers vraiment d'une
complexité addiction même si
l'ordinateur leur de bien aimer la
position de maxime ou à la jauge noir
commencé là à descendre alors après tout
quand même s'accrocher parce qu'ils
proposent tous des six mais j'ai envie
de te dire moi un truc qui me ferait
peur c'est peut-être je sais pas si je
prise en premier ou touré vii mais
peut-être tout premier set on apprend
17.17 la tour carrée grand f 7 mondial
pam du fou en prison sonia lapointe de
pour son courage ouais et c'est le
cavalier qui peut rebondir je les
regarde j'ai vu vous prendra le 1er set
j'étais nice est très tendue mais c'est
vrai qu'à cavaliers prend et il n'y a
pas de maths parce que le roi s'échappe
mais oui tout ça faut le voir pour
maxime
on va lui faire confiance quand même
parce que ça c'est sa spécialité de
calculer ce genre de choses et tout bien
voir al avance et il peut il peut très
bien trouver un coup comme
food et 6 pour échanger un maximum de
pièces et ils valoriser ces deux points
de plus à l'est c'est peut-être possible
de remporter
alors l'autre coup qu'on pourrait
vouloir faire c'est tourner vite pour
les noirs on s'en va on s'en va mais ça
tu vois par exemple et non à
l'ordinateur n'aime pas du tout ça
montre la complexité de la position
parce que c'est un autre coup tout à
fait logique hein t'as pas créé la tour
les tue ton vote au tour 3 3 défense
s'il défend bien tôt ou que celle
aimerait pas et attend ça secoue plus
évident et là ce serait dur alors maxime
qui vient de jouer mais à mon avis là je
me fous des six il a joué tous les six
mois le dossier
c'est un athlète il a tout vu il a tout
vu et fabien il a absolument tout vu
maxime il a tous les coups du tennis
tous les coups d échec et il a vu toutes
les variantes à base de deux tours avec
celles qui ne marchent pas avec ce qui
embellit qui rebondit et ailleurs
d'ailleurs pour soi peut-être que la
dame était beaucoup mieux en g3 quand
j'ai quatre pour éviter ce chou décès
est probablement rien mais pour en
reprendre de la dame en 5 et à maxime
qui va probablement mettre son sa
première victoire son premier point avec
les pièces noires c'est la partie de
notre avenir est très mal autant il ne
reste plus qu'une minute
on va voir on va voir comment radjabov
peut tenter de garder de la complexité
dans cette position mais il y aura aussi
un coup peut-être comme fouet f7 fabien
je sais pas ce que ça vaut mais je crois
87 points et 7 ya le vieux fou qui
arrive tout le temps aux prises afin de
varier entre 9 c'est un poil en fait
c'est vrai que l'on m'avait parlé très
tôt dans la partie que faire un petit
coucou ouachin peut-être mais il a
jamais trop le temps et
et ça se paye à la fin ouais il peut
plus faire grand chose il va faire prier
faire fou prend des six mais bon mes
forces et mon temps à les refaire pas
tout reprend 17 puis vous prendrez 6 mes
jambes débat il a plus que 10 secondes 9
artistes décident mais je crois qu'il a
que des mauvais choix à la fff 7 et bien
ça peut être tout recours au cloud pro 5
comme on est dans le regard d un tour
prend donc là on n'a pas le temps de
prendre ici parce qu'on serait prendre
sur échec de l'autre côté exact donc il
faudrait prendre
henri vii il faut prend feu il faut
prendre les catastrophes ada pour les
blancs puisque lé nord est la paire le
fou contre une tour est toujours leurs
fans ou d'options mais ça commence à
faire beaucoup
paris 6e partir un an pour tomber s'être
[Musique]
c'est pas mal mais ça qui accueille
prend 1,7 qui est toute emprise mais qui
attaque tout c'est difficile à voir
c'est le coureur de grand tour ou
apprend torse et on reprendra donc on
attend 6 à 30 tours reprend un tour
d'aman cavaliers mais bon allez toujours
les deux points de plus et le problème
c'est qu'on a toujours ce clouage un
métier paris vii c'est ça qui l'a pas vu
fabien non mais la patrouille la plus
folle et puis que quelques secondes
il fallait jouer la coupe necker paris
vii donc ici d'un me prend et citons
quand dame de reprendre la même chose
encore tu vas pouvoir regagner peut-être
même pas en fait tu as to tatou en plus
un peu en crise là bas et puis les noirs
mais il en faut plus pour finir comme ça
et un abandon directe de la part des
blancs à mais ça il faut le voir c'est
pas du tout calculé après peut-être même
deux bonnes options pour l'honneur mais
comme on l'a dit maxime il a encore pas
mal de temps la pendule est la plus de
six minutes et calcule bien alors
peut-être plus rassurant fabien fou
prend 1,5
toute cette frange et vous aimez les
trois sets 3-6
car il est si ce bordel en branle à tour
et puis on a deux pièces pour la toile
oui c'est plus le scénario vers lequel
on se dirige c'est une tour qui arrive
on arrive cette sas est pas encore tout
à fait fini mais fausse et 6
heureusement parce que en fait vu qu'ils
allaient attaquer fausse blonde défendre
son défunt éclats d'âme run ce qu'elle
est coincé parce que le fousseret plus
défendre enfin il est défendu meilleure
tactique
grâce à ce club qui immobilisait ce pion
des 4 du coup d'éclat dame doit bouger
et ben il ya plus mais par contre le
fait qu'on est le petit poucet six fans
variantes qui blain de tout le cavalier
défendu la dame est restée à ça se passe
sur un clouage et ben les blancs il
manquera quelque chose à faire est si
lente
ouais ça devrait aller en finale sur mon
cou comme roy h1y si j'imagine on s'en
va que fruits quelque part la balle
embellie de prud'hommes c'est ça ton
plus et ougrée la batterie difficile en
club de calculer tout ça de loin de
l'évaluer aussi un voilà ce que la
position n'est pas simple à évaluer son
entourage cette dame c est une forme
feront très un tour en abscisse
admettons ces genres doigt lorsque tu
peux dire de loin
tu préfères forcément les noirs mais est
ce que tu es si bien c'est qu'elle dure
évalué quelqu'un qui peut allier en b 4
que d'autres faire un truc comme a5b 4
le fameux plan dont on parle depuis très
longtemps que maintenant je vais le
mettre en oeuvre
c'est hyper compliqué quatre minutes
pour maxime on a juste le temps de faire
un passage éclair les vonn qui met une
vraie pression est maintenant sur son
jeune adversaire sur food et 6 pour
couvrir le pian et carey price est dont
la date c'est plus le genre de fille
d'alain c'est pas les trois pions de la
même ce sera des pions disloqué et ça ça
peut ça doit perdre si c'est comme ça je
retournais ici à ton premier set up et
il faudra regarder du coup h six
cavaliers trois fous des six mais il
semble que le pion le pion des six va
tomber tôt ou tard un pôle qui ont des
cinq pardon va tomber tôt ou tard donc
les blancs vont avoir une pression le
docteur contrat ni sghir and is gay qui
est vraiment pas en forme dans ce
tournant un kasparov pourrait vraiment
se passer lui s'il continue enchaîné les
contre-performances là il est de nouveau
très mal le pion plus pour amin bassem
qui devrait
l'emporté avec les blancs mal mal autant
plus anish giri ça se passe mal et
dernière position alors là c'est devenu
la guerre des tranchées
fabien est bien fait les bleus ont gagné
mais pour combien de temps voilà un pion
des cinq attaqué trois fois et ne dure
pas longtemps mais ils vendent l'option
des 5 passes et les deux joueuses ont
pas trop de temps en fait tout peut se
passer
allez ça là ça va c'est du tout peut
tout peut arriver et du coup la victoire
de maxime est vraiment importante pour
la team europe dont il a alors il a joué
fouet ce système il a tout rond des huit
finalement fou prend aussi ce qu'a
réussi ce d'atouts reprend 17 pour
apprendre et c'est tout bref cette
fougue sept cavaliers de 3 alors
l'allemagne et l'inde ont joué depuis
tout à l'heure alors la position est
incroyable hardy qui n'arrive pas à se
décider un départ ils m'ont ils
descendent bien que l'esprit voit bien
quoi il ya une pièce que justin pied un
plan une pièce est un pion plus pour le
joueur français
mais cluj est partout il écrite par toi
retour est fixé ultra logique tour h7
c'est logique aussi 34 secondes team
radjabov qui va récupérer dix secondes
par coup hein c'est la règle contre 4
minutes pour maxime et des clouage
multiples le coût de l'ordinateur ici
numéro 1 à 0 à des 8es ses fables coup
le plus logique puisque ça sort des deux
courage en un seul exactement comme ça
les deux pièces sont réactivés et
pourront bouger mais en plus cela les
blancs et j'aimerais bien continuer avec
ce cavalier là pourrait rejoindre
l'attaquant venant en aide 5 et un coup
comme toi reprend pion à la justice pour
focaliser la taxe sur le cavalier en
incite donc les blancs en fait qu'il
garde du potentiel est là encore tout
est possible tout est logique que cette
pièce en plus pour lancer le fou
bessette inquiets spectateurs de la
partie palmarès du foot bessette je
défends des cinq exactement alors un
jour s'il revient c'est vite ou six
options des cinq semaines avancé il aura
son mot à dire mais pour l'instant ça
qu'il a rien fait du tout mais il ya un
dicton que j'aime bien à propos d'un
hameau est fou comme ça c'est un mauvais
flou défend des banques sans papiers le
champ des cinq du coup il avait défendu
paul témoin tâte le faron ça reste quand
même un palmarès assez
dans les gènes mais bon mais j'ai un
truc marrant c'est que repousser vite
pour montrer que sert à quelque chose
j'aurais tout reprendre cette province
est du coup très vite en fait le marché
sur le madame colle et il a fait dame à
sainte-maxime alors ça c'est très
intéressant parce qu'il menace dames 1
pour venir contre attaquer de manière
est clair c'est qu'on clique harley ce
qui va faire cavalier f5 qui permettrait
d'éviter la double attaque
voilà c'était un courage de cd de coûts
qui viennent spontanément à la tête pour
france 2 pour éviter l'échec et qui
avait les cinq ans dire j'ai eu la
double attaque et je fais mon boulot
ailleurs callas encore une chance de nul
avec un truc à un trailer pour prendre
un prend et la dame qui le faire les
chèques corps des tués lorsque j'ai
vraiment perpétuelle cette échelle et
damages 3 mais bon oui c'est vrai que
les plans n'ont aucun intérêt
quelle position compliquée côté maxime
fabien sait maintenant que tout va se
passer
même sans forcer parce que si tu vas te
faire un ouais mais tu as match 4 alors
après une fois qu'on en est là de toute
façon ça m'a froissé idiot tentative
d'échangé puis tu joues avec eux de
pierre kutwa il va faire b4 c3 les
compagnies oui donc non il ya maintenant
sûrement nul
si c'est ça la partie alors à temps
est-ce que maxime est obligé de faire
mieux parce que là à vrai dire alors
menace price is not for this way we
trouve un coût 1 puisque là le roi peut
plus aller en 18 comme tout à l'heure
parce qu'il aurait dans le trou québec
est maintenant sur ta match 4 en plus
sûrs et à ma voix est là on est très
heureux de garde finalement là nul ne
m'intéresse plus ça m'a intéressé
pendant un bon petit moment mais là je
vais me reprendre un cahier non ça
serait la mauvaise opération pour la
team europe 1 pas que ce soit une
contre-performance pour maxime mais
c'est vrai que vu la pendule et vu la
position on espérait une victoire du
joueur français mais après quand on a vu
les variantes à l'ordinateur c'était
extrêmement difficile de trouver un bon
c'était peut-être trouvable peu importe
ce n'était pas pas trivial en tout cas
bon il ya quand même là nul en poche les
potes pourquoi alors dit non mais cette
barbe blanche trio
parce qu'il a vu sur trois points 50 il
a rien ok juste il bat il a un peu
halluciné redescendre et il va ya un
petit perpétuelle comme on avait dit
donc j'ai vues actuelles sous la
pression se répète indéfiniment manière
perpétuelle est donc là nulle d'être
déclarée d'accord
la belle défense de timour en finale
m'enfin défense attaque attaque défense
belles belles passes d'armes entre les
deux hommes est tout bonnement milieu de
partie partie animée avec j'espère
salaire du coup tout va et c'est
d'ailleurs chez guy richard onians
eschena alors les bonnes pourvoirie là
il a gagné depuis on fait juste un tour
express pape qui il peut gagner donc à
gagner on va choisir un échiquier sur
lequel on va se focaliser lui peu peur
il doit perdre avec riz noir c'est quasi
sûr alors je les flux sont trop fort
mais un tour - et ceux qui ont passé
comme tu le montre le fou vahid est à la
fois sur ce pont jusqu'où maxime
l'annuler signé il fait un peu la moue
on voit sur la caméra il sait qu'il est
passé proche de la victoire le docteur
qui est mieux est juste on va regarder
et à et nana qui a gardé son son pion de
son champion plus ouais donc la très
belle opération poils qui donc
maintenant à son compte plus en plus
avions passé centrale et elle a très bon
avantage l'histoire des trois c'est pas
possible parce qu'il ya tour quand vous
échouez de mon fils est donc bon train
et ils m'ont vu que les noirs vont avoir
du mal à faire cette défense derrière
puis en basset
plutôt bon signe pour le camp de la taxe
voilà ces dernières je vous fous de
fabien elle va couper le roi le roi n'en
a pas être complètement coupée elle est
obligée de recul avec le fou pour le
garder mais peut-être la tour avoir
commencé à venir
c est prendre peut-être même le tueur de
5 regarde fabien pour obtenir deux pions
passé lié côté à côté européen
complètement donc je pense que tu vas
gagner et donc tout va je vais sûrement
sur la partie de l'ebn aaron oui donne
un peu de chez les jeunes qui comme tu
vas plus petites secondes ça on peut
peut-être laissé juste si ça joue vite
ici ce que les veines ça risque de
traîner non soit peu ce à sallertaine
c'est vrai très gagnant alors les phones
il a quoi il a le à hilla le tout le
camion contre contre 3 mais ça avec le
pion pas céder ok je sais pas si ça
gagne c'est intéressant je crois que ça
gagne pas mais c'est très pénible à
défendre et je pense qu'il va la gagner
femme s'est en fait il ya des cas de
figure suivants où elles font plus s'il
est complètement sur la colonne 1
c'est censé faire nul très souvent et
puis plus rapproche plus et ayant leurs
règles et on a plus de chances de gagner
qu'avec un c'était un cc na waie mais
dès le problème c'est que c'est quand
même très proche aussi du roi adverse
mais sûrement qu'on voudrait c'est loupé
mais bon ça reste difficile à défendre
ça reste difficile parce que toute façon
les blancs on raconte plus et donc les
noirs la moindre erreur là ça peut être
décisif
et puis halte en russie bon par contre
bien sûr le jeu avec les normes book un
livre est offert aux jo on le sent très
à l'aise avec peu de temps la pendule
expert des partitions internet donc sage
lui il fait pas plus peur que ça le
bronze d'avoir trente secondes à la
pendule ou quelque chose comme ça ouais
mais les finales technique c'est son
point faible
exactement alors avoir peu de temps même
si tu es à l'aise sur ton point faible
c'est paris moi pas j'ai 180 voix faible
et je pense qu'il doit pas être heureux
d'être mal autant dans une opposition
comme ça contre contraint les douanes
aronian qui pour le coup et technicums
très technique ouais j'avais peut-être
faire un tour ces deux essais de fer
droit saissac un peu avancé fiant je
sais pas difficulté section s'est assis
sa seconde option steve de g3 je dois
peut-être serais-je et 3h 4 c'était plus
facile à une structure de pions un peu
enlevée ouais c'est pas terrible si tu
fais hk tu vois des tours a chargé de
faire g3 il fera t-on g1 c'est pas si tu
fais g4 qui peut faire h4 être joué sur
le pion h 3 qui sera faible
c'est juste sa voix qui m'inquiète un
peu pour les bonnes complètement
complètement c'est loin d'être gagné
sabri tu vois moi j'aimerais bien faire
un petit coup comme tours 2 qui mange
pas de pain mais pour poser une question
si tu fais roi m6 était toujours en ac 5
et j'essaye de faire un dessin croix des
six est là juste pour la chine l'a
emporté pour les états unis
encore une défaite de dominguez
entraîneur américain qui est étonnant et
qui s'entête à à titulariser le joueur
d'origine cubaine et qui enchaîne trois
défaites consécutives c'est ça ouais
mais en plus car on avait fait le taf il
a gagné contre sa bête noire manga ou où
il fan a fait le point comme prévu à
l'échec et numéro quatre est basse et
jouer les numéros 3 et 1
et en plus dans une case à perdre avec
les blancs tatras ans s'est fait mal à
l'équipe le genre avec les pièces
blanches se faire écoutons prend oui oui
bien sûr ses autres concurrents directs
bon bah du coup la chine pas tout le
monde caracole en tête et donc devrait
logiquement se qualifier même si encore
une phase retour à disputer bien
évidemment mais sont tellement bien
partie ils sont tellement solide
tellement en forme je vois mal ce qui
pourrait leur alors que nana l'a emporté
1 / sur le pipeline celui qui est bien
guéri hyper toujours guérir complètement
fichue guy est là encore un décès c'est
les choix choix étrange 1,2 de garry
kasparov de titulariser guéri comme ça
qui est en super forme et qui va encore
perdre c'est vrai que les entraîneurs on
a des grands noms des échecs mais c'est
vrai que les choix sont peut les
remettre en cause un femme on a le droit
les grands joueurs font pas toujours de
grands entraîneurs ouais c'est vrai que
le choix de m geary contrat mine basse
elle dans une partie un gris un peu hors
forme hamid ben hassen fantasque tu vois
je pense qu'un joueur comme bouddha
aurait eu son mot à dire et par
extension à tous d'aller encore les
choix sont faciles à critiquer a
posteriori mais quand même c'était des
choix osé de la part de l'entraîneur
américains et leurs entraîneurs
européens et de mauvais choix tu es
c'est toujours pareil quand tu fait
jouer un joueur censé être moins fort et
qui perd ses yeux attentifs et sakho qui
gagne je veux dire par là que titularisé
duda qui perd on aurait venir dit
c'était le choix logique
non elle dans la rolls des médicaments
commandés pas su non pour le coup
évidemment sur la technologie kth comme
suit la voie se laisse aux équipes herbe
à la tamise en équipe type et a perdu
les services ça peut arriver mais de
faire tourner et de perles assez plus
critiquable évidemment alors pour le
moment
ali reza qui oppose une belle défense a
mais il va peut-être finir par craquer
en tout cas on l'espère est-ce qu'il va
revenir attaqué le pion g3 rarement la
tour soit seconde rangée la 3d manger
qui a donné un échec avant ça va pas
changer grand chose
si dan l'échec-avant il fera tomber
quatre rappels dans les nouveaux
redescend finale de pions avec un revers
de plus son sont quasiment toujours
gagnante un oui il ya des cas trio ça
peut faire mieux mais normalement c'est
pas vraiment le scénario de défense
alors là il ya un catalyseur des cinq
tours prend des cinq on donne le pion to
b 6 davy le roi et dans ces finales la
priorité au roi qui arrive en premier il
va raser tous les pions et le pion h à
la fin il filera adam donc des cinq
échecs à mon avis va jouer s'est joué à
l'est il avance le pion il a réussi
enfin à passer la marche avant mais déjà
un bon chrono
ouais mais est-ce que ça va vraiment
être utile au genre et bien sûr ça de
pris plaçons dans une finale même si
elle est nulle
certains le savent le faire et toi bats
tu fais ce que tu peux pour avancer
petit à petit faire progrès par progrès
chèrement ça s'arrête ça s'arrête mais
c'est officiel un gi à guérir la tête
sous l'eau il a perdu un moment donné il
va falloir prendre les prendre ses
responsabilités côté kasparov et faire
et faire les bons choix
parce que parce que ghilas et commence à
nous coûter cher
heureusement qu'on a les bonnes on est
toujours pas si les bonnes va l'emporter
dans cette partie ou pas mais en tout
cas il fait sa partie il leur a mis la
pression ils essayent il donne tout il
fait son effort il a déjà sauvé l'équipe
à deux reprises
oui oui là et en plus c'est il ne m'est
jamais son équipe pendant je l'espère
que c'est une pression
c'est une pression qui ne peut que
rapporter le point ils ne font aucun
risque les bones et c'est encore une
partie majuscule du joueur arménien tu
fait vraiment du bien
si sans lui c'est vrai que on en serait
loin mais j'ai l'impression qu'il fait
des progrès fabien elle doit toujours
être nul mais il y force et force son
adversaire à trouver des défenses
peut-être qu'il peut donner dans
certaines nantes un pion h4 pour ramener
son roi vers le centre et réussira à toi
avec le le pion le pion des cinq convois
qui fait pas mal de grimaces à la caméra
il est bouillant regarde il est
bouillant fabien il est bouillant les
bonnes il est bouillant que ceux qui ont
des seins qui m excellence tu peux t'on
rang des six pas s'y attarde bouclier
contre deux échecs clients et par
derrière et tu perds 10 réseaux de maths
forcé le roi des rats s'en aller et que
ton tube du groupe va lancer facilement
je suis comme ça c'est bien joué j'ai
l'impression de la part de deux firent
ouja qui utilisent le fait qu'en dedans
des échecs
le roi ne pourrait pas arriver jusqu'en
m6 donc si le roi venait vers la case de
cinq familles à la tour pour y vivre
il aurait pas de refuge j'aurais pas ils
n'auraient pas accès mais mel evans va
bien trouver quelque chose il peut soit
faire tour ses six échecs avant je vais
partir mais y perdraient la protection
du pion il peut aussi faire peut-être
tour à 6 pour lorsque le roi arrive en
ces cinq heures à l'idée de faire tout
retour à cet échec
il va tenter des petits pièges pas reçus
par la torah six ans notre intéressant
je sais pas moi j'aurais eu le feeling
pour ce coup là après et surtour g4
peut-être faire broyer roi ici 400 seuil
et peut-être de mettre un danger c'est
pas bien éléments pense c'est toi le ce
temps le grand maître ah non mais le
problème du taux refi retour à cette 3d
vite broie désir
retour ici après on va pas y arriver
malheureusement ça ne gagnerait pas mais
pas loin pas gaza peut être comptable 1
on se dit en pratique qui s'appuie par
ailleurs c'est toujours la position ou
où il n'y a pas de risque c'est à dire
pile pile je gagne face je fais nul ou
la verse et vice et versa il a fait tour
à 6 il a fait du bon feeling sur mon
feeling sais pas c'est bon signe fabien
jallet maso qui a fait roi en 17 et
pottas donc le plan de grasse et cinq
directions m6 c'était l'objectif 1
surtout raciste de provoquer y aura 17
donc ne pas rentrer dans la ville de
farah qui évidemment faisait nul très
facilement mais mais provoqué ce soir 17
et maintenant si tu fais les échecs les
pas dû aller me planquer en bref 6 mai
et seulement voilà c'est exactement
fabien il rentre exactement dans le
piège tendu
là on est vraiment bien fabien je crois
qu'à lire les arts vient de craquer on à
dire fragile fragile avec le techno les
examinerait le roi file vers les 6 et
puis après jackson tissu pour aller
ranger 7
et puis peut-être temps prendre ici
c'est c'est alors on peut peut-être
tomber dans la phase finale avec f et h
contre rien mais hockey qui est sensé 2
nuls aussi mais bon pour la défendre
c'est plus dur parce qu'il y avait à
défendre jusque là des progrès sont
faits on voit les vols du coup tu as qui
ce qui sera en position
et là il a encore un peu progressé allez
les bonnes
c'est peut-être encore nul
malheureusement mais ça s'apprend chaque
tour est vite peut être un coup ici
fabien je me savoir des six ont fait un
petit coup des chèques et on chasse et
si je redescends on va installer prend
que j'ai 6 alors que l'on serait passé
par septième rangée on a pu perdre ce
pion très vite oui exactement
touraille 8 et je pense sur un coup
comme tour g4 fabien peut-être leroy
revient aux 5
on donne le théâtre et maintenant on
monte
peut-être comme ça genre de scénario
mais là le roi
sans aller de des cases devant le curé
et puis ça va grandement faciliter la
vie pour ça peut finir comme ça à mon
avis avec un jeu parfait s'est pas
encore fait mais ça peut ça a dit non il
se rapproche de plus en plus du
précipice le pire aux jo c'est marrant
quand même ce roi des scènes jouées par
le joueur iranien
ouais parce que c'était c'était vraiment
l'idée de delémont bas complètement
l'idée à la route vers m6 donc on
enlevait la pièce qui bloqua cette route
la route était ouverte et il n'a pas
fait attention
est ce que j aime bien aussi c'est de
voir ces douars les bonnes tu as utilisé
tout son temps c'est à dire qu'il n'a
pas à jouer vite pour jouer vite pour
jeter la partie il a joué vite au début
pour mettre la pression et maintenant
les 8 9 10 minutes qu'il avait d'avancis
les met à profit pour moi nous monter la
pression sur fear ouja et faire craquer
le jeune joueur iranien ou qu'un leeuwen
vraiment millésima complètement
complètement il fait j'ai un gros retour
à la première est d'être un peu dur la
mise en route mais là deux victoires
d'affilée et là il met grosse pression à
son adversaire tout cas la team reste du
monde sous pression la team u 17 u a dit
a perdu contre la chine donc l'europe
qui pourrait recoller là
prendre la seconde place du classement 1
alors il a joué avec tour à 7 3 et 6
c'est un coup que tu devrais jouer quand
même assez vite on voit firoud déjà
hésitant fabien ali reza qui hésite un
il rejette encore 15 20 secondes roi des
huit ça ne peut pas aller fabien
activement sa sauvegarde pense ça se
regarde même pas et il jette vraiment du
temps on le sent pas papa à l'aise dans
ces finales technique et tours j'ai sept
thèmes pourris la même pas il ya même
très mouvant il l'a même pas réfléchi le
courroye des huit semblait vraiment
impossible pour les bonnes maintenant
tour g4 c'est vraiment le seul coup
encore une fois pour aller prendre ceux
qui ont acheté ce faire un petit peu de
contre je bien évidemment les blancs
c'est leur choix c'est aussi mais ça va
être une course est souvent dans ce
genre finale est payant un sacrifice de
tours contre le pion bassin cet
adversaire pour courir un roi et pion
ensemble et forcé à faire à son tour ce
sacrifice à tour un petit peu plus tard
alors pourquoi un cat et aussi peut-être
une option fabien roy g53 cinq tours 6 3
en dessin croix pour un f4 hu a aussi
ses logements auraient le temps mais on
vous fait pas peur au prince 5 avant
pour le jetpack découvrit peut-être mais
je crois que alors attendu tourcoing ft
à troyes g5 c'est justement la partie
mais avec du roi branche 5 oui peut-être
ici du coup oui voilà c'est ça mais
peut-être on peut jouer des six
intermédiaire fabien encore mieux parce
qu'on apprend des 5 c'est une nulle
théorique un web java dot et je pense
qu'une fois que de couper le roi mais
c'est vrai que la tour en fait elle
immobilise ébats des six décès se
désiste utoya nouvelle fois en fait non
pas tourné six évidemment c'est moi qui
fait bugger l'applet mes pions des 6 es
le roi noir serait coupé horizontalement
et surtour des quatre gardes c'est aussi
intéressant si les noms venus signé le
pion des six les blancs seraient juste à
temps avec roy g7 pour bloquer le retour
du roi et envoyer le pion à dam de vonn
qui a joué fabien et il a joué des six
tours des quatre héros approche 5
maintenant qui arrive et il voudra faire
wife 5 peut-être
je vois rira bien ça se rapproche
ils paieront des parentes
il ya soit encore free qui s'est pas
encore prêt fait feu mais écoute de
l'action de plus nul ça passe un tour de
plus on avance un peu toujours un peu
nul avec deux points de plus à un moment
allait progresser je pense travail
allait mal et les bonnes il faut y aller
il faut y aller maintenant
alors la difficulté c'est que je veux
pas pousser les pions des jeux suivants
pour prendre et on peux pas trop bouger
notre heure s'ils prendront donc notre
autre pion donc falloir manoeuvrer pour
arriver à se dépatouiller de spéciaux
bloqué on va dire mais mais j'ai bien
confiance en les bonnes si tu vois notre
une petite manoeuvre on peut faire un
tour j'ai cinq mètres le roi sur m6 et
après enlevez la tour peut-être et
peut-être même en g4 fabien ce qu'il
veut pas avec les noix prendre le pion
des puisqu'il y aurait tout rejet 6 on
va échanger les tours et je voulais
faire du droit donc tu parles cela avec
laurent blanc maintenant j'ai sept
bloquer le retour du roi there sari
hanafi roissy seront achetés roi g7
alors la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que
l'ordinateur pense que c'est nul
la bonne nouvelle c'est que ça me paraît
très très chaud à réaliser gilbert
collard pc la tour un chien et si on
veut tourner quatre sapeurs c'est ça
j'imagine ouais mais son idée c'est que
si tu fais royal 7 tours à vii et quand
tu couvres leur or à l'élan de courir ok
six autres sophie la combattre les
mandats du vieux village et 3,4 et tour
à quatre c'est le fou qui perd tour hcc
s'est finie femmes c'est facile
maintenant le roi se rapproche du pion
et des sept des huit séries
ah ben c'est simple comme bonjour moi
j'ai ça mais les 17 et la tour viande et
cissé on pousse il a craqué il a craqué
fil rouge a hérité perdre son équipe à
lui tout seul fabien ouais moi pas
cueilli les perspectives
c'est l'idée d'un fonds de type de ce
critère son équipe mais voilà les
progrès qui ce fait les petits mais
heureux il est heureux les bonnes amg
roulait encore
toujours avant pourquoi pas dès que les
17 et encore tour des quatre secteurs
des cartes parce qu'ils coûtent toujours
je ne sais où
brasilia jouer et son voir l'avenir
tenir l'audition et on va pousser au qui
rendra un comble du sénat jay mohr a
besoin de le faire
minimum ouais ouais c c'est la fête côté
européen fabien il l'a fait craquer le
petit ouais mais bon
technique en finale est toujours
important non mais pour le coup là c'est
écrit dans cette partie et autres
autrefois peut même aller vonn qui fait
une petite terrasse ombragée cet
appareil excède ce qu'il a vu ce plan là
mais il y avait une chance de sauver et
il l'a passée donc il a raté trop
d'opportunités de défense est donc là
pour moi le moment le culte pour moi le
moment le plus est la tour 1 et le front
du sénat qui mord moi le bon le truc
riant c'est quand il a pris 30 secondes
pour jeu roi des six alors que c'est
leur paraît qu'il a été obligé de
comprendre par le calcul au lieu de qui
laissait c'est peut-être un des plus
doués au niveau du calcul 1 mais il n'a
pas compris grâce à la technique aux
connaissances et par ok par le calcul et
la bande ne voit la fa temps mais voilà
les bonnes vielles et aux jeunes
trois matches de suite ian y aller tout
seul car il équipe les caries l'équipe
est-ce que du bien d'avoir un joueur en
renfort dans une équipe fatiguée
l'emploi est il du coup ben ali donne il
donne toutes ses chances à cette équipe
d'europe
souvent devant la grande finale
alors on va regarder les scores des
autres matches ensemble donc la chine
autre bonne nouvelle qui par les usa
deux et demi à un point et demi et
et on va regarder le résultat de la
russie qui n'a fait que match nul contre
l'inde
donc au classement afin de gagner car
les kings ou non sa valeur bien d'accord
entre partenaires qui fait un gros
bouton à obtient fabien ça va bien se
passer au niveau du sang ding bouton add
artemiev avec la chine qui caracole en
tête 2e europe et maintenant c'est les
russes et les américains qui doivent qui
doivent marquer à tous les matchs là si
la france la france - l'europe
je sais je suis chaud baba la russie on
pourra dire que ce sera ça en sera fini
des espoirs russes se faire bien dans
cette compétition
havas semblablement oui rassemblement
est donc balle de balkanisation des
russes que j'aime bien en tout cas c'est
en train bien se passer et j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on était si impérial que
c'est au niveau du contenu série contre
l'unfp on a eu en est pas mal de chance
c'est finalement là depuis ce match nice
qui est bien tournée on vient de battre
coup sur coup à l'équipe des états unis
et l'équipe du reste du monde
alors j'ai pas envie de dire en contrôle
pour le reste du monde mais on a quand
même tant dans le contenu était était
supérieur non mais je crois que c'est un
gars méritée dans ce match parce que
maxime était plutôt mieux oui direct
départ en danger car c'est bon il a fait
nul mais plutôt rade labeouf qui était
sur le fil de rage au dur at war à
rognan il dépasse sûr de gagner mais pas
il du bon côté c'est lui qui mettait la
pression et finalement ça a marché
guibon lui par contre il a pris l'eau
mais en même temps nana a bien gagné
donc ça compense donc pas deux premiers
chic et on était plutôt du côté à mettre
la pression
oui et finalement il ya une partie qui
est passé de notre côté avec les bonnes
donc
donc ça c'est cool alors est ce que tu
sais à quelle heure ça va reprendre la
nappe une partie ça reprend à 17 heures
donc dans 40 minutes fabien à 17h à une
belle pause belle pause ils ont décidé
de reporter c'était c'était avant à
16h45 et décision était prise de
repousser le début de la ronde à 17
heures
peut-être que demain sera 7h30 pour bien
laisser le temps de souffler aux joueurs
comme il faut pourquoi pas 10 parce
qu'il voulait une demi heure de pause
entre les rampes d'après ce que le
règlement y avait écrit une demi heure
de pause et pour une raison que je ne
m'expliquerai jamais fabien aux échecs
contrairement à tous les autres sports
individuels que je peux suivre
on n'utilise jamais la note not before
donc tu pourras voir un autre dit fort
16h45 qui se trouve juste azar 56 jamais
mais là non surtout pas c'est pas de
bombe et du coup ne pas braquer l'a40
ministre l'a bien sympa c'est quoi non
sans avoir à toucher est ce qu'on fait
je vais thierry est sauvé je domine days
ou pas la grosse inflexion encore bien
reposé fabien qu'est ce que tu penses
qu'à ses 30
non pour le coup je tombe bien on va
attendre un peu je pense que d'ici une
petite dizaine de n'étonnera les compos
j'imagine
j'imagine que on aura le retour de duda
le tâtre à la place de l'evam qui sert
fait quoi on s'est pas fait les bonnes
qui doit sortir final four après trois
victoires on sait jamais qui perdent à
la prochaine mer mais du coup la bonne
façon d'aller 230 ou bien et là ils ont
du coup c'est quoi ce match contre les
russes one way ses matchs contre les
russes prennent virus qui devrait faire
sortir nepomniachi à fond ici mais c'est
très possible je regarde où on vient
leur poser aussi pour pour la suite du
tendre désolé les femmes mais valence
est sûr à 100 mais je suis sensible
c'était parce que je me sentais très
espiègle très taquin tripac c'était très
drôle donc donc ça devrait par exemple
ça reprend à 17 heures les joueurs tout
le monde a quitté j'avais promis de
mettre l'art mitre si rare et donc je
mettrais un petit coup d'arbitré je
mettrai les arbitres mais gens qui n'ont
pas compris dans le nord mais on a pris
un fou rire sur sur les poses aux échecs
mais parce que c'est pas la première
mais mariano delgado
si vous suivez depuis un moment les
échecs c'est c'est très drôle mais ça ex
qui me suivaient pas assidûment
il y avait il ya période exceptionnelle
mordre olmert mais pas comique de
répétition est là et c c'est juste qu'il
ya souvent un peu la même chose qui se
reproduit dans tous les tournois et on
n'a pas forcément facilité à comprendre
pourquoi donc
donc ça nous amuse c'est pour ça donc
alors euros dont qui nous écrit andré
sérieusement je pense que firent ont
déjà fuit roumanie se défieront déjà
fait mozilla clad d'un spa ti routes
d'ibiza
je crois que je suis déjà houleuse et
avant le 2e en fait firouzi déjà moqué
de la girouette
et pas encore assez fort pour se frotter
à l'élite des échecs il encore besoin de
s'entraîner et de grandir un petit peu
nous dirons grasset on voit on a bien vu
ces défauts qui ont été mis en exergue
par par les bonnes c'est ça après bah
évidemment il n'a que 16 ans peut-être
17 entre les deux vallées ben oui faut
encore qu'il s'exerce que c'est naturel
il faut prendre de l'expérience etc etc
comme n'importe quel jeune joueur dans
n'importe quelle discipline qu'ils
s'aguerrissent qui prennent de
l'expérience mais on voit déjà ses gros
gros gros point fort et qui tient déjà
tata ses joueurs donc pas encore
exactement le niveau
fatigué mais moins fort encore mais avec
un peu de temps il a une chance qui
arrive et ça c'est un des grands espoirs
après bien sûr n'est jamais sûr que les
espoirs j'ai espoir on perd c'est
jusqu'au bout mais il a le talent pour
voilà ça on sait jamais non tu peux pas
savoir s'il va réussir à combler ces
lacunes
c'est ça est-ce que ses points forts il
va les garder
s'il a gardé les mêmes motivations si on
a beaucoup travaillé je sais pas en fait
par exemple regarder le joueur chinois
oui qu'on voyait comme un futur champion
du monde
peut-être qu'il le sera d'ailleurs mais
parce qu'ils étaient passés à plus de
2700 l'âge de 16 ans c'était le plus
jeune de l'histoire c'est incroyable à
quoi est donc tous enflammé sur lui et
palmarès c'est comme ces cinq ans plus
tard il n'a pas bougé palmarès et un
diplôme mais oui il avoue ses études en
fait ils avaient d'autres trucs dans sa
vie et puis bah en fait c'est tout à son
honneur parce que rien ne peut se faire
que des échecs et voilà mais à mon avis
il est pas bref peu de chance grosfils
parloir champion du monde en fait voilà
oui
ah oui oui tu peux même dire avec ya
plus aucune chance à mon avis oui bon
après écoute ses chats mais je n'aime
pas m'engager à fond comme ça la vie est
très présente
là je suis un fossé c'est sûr qu'il sera
qui sera jamais non non non sur femmes
après je sais pas imaginer un scénario
où l'un corolla qui empêche tout le
monde de jouer ça fait les joueurs
chinois disent mal en ses chances même
nom non même pas non mais c'était
scénario céder ses biens la ccvg passé
un peu alambiqué quoi envie de se dire
c'est dans le scénario
en cas de non mais il a pris façon il a
même arrêté sa carrière
mais ce soir il y joue et j'ai encore
une excellent niveau j'en voyais il a
encore une encore 20e mondiale quoi donc
pour un joueur amateur c'est fantastique
il est vraiment amateur 1 pour la peine
en plus c'est n'avait pas elle c'est pas
une blague
non non c'est à dire qu'il a énormément
travaillé et même la plus de
connaissances que pas mal de joueurs qui
sont bons pros mais mais en ce moment
tout cas il a repris ses études donc je
n'ai pas de diplôme de poids mais il va
bien il est pas focalisé à fond sur les
échecs on a on a connu gata kamsky dans
les joueurs de vraiment premier rôle qui
a été professeur à une époque et puis
qui est devenu un joueur amateur aussi
et quand il est revenu il a fait très
très mal il a même failli reprendre la
fin prendre la couronne mondiale
puisqu'ils ont acclamé été champion du
monde donc et partie revenu mais cannes
ce qu'il avait quand même un autre
pedigree que que oui bah oui cirque amsc
il a été finaliste du championnat du
monde fim et de 1996 il est le groupe
karpov à cette époque là est aussi il a
été demi finaliste je pense du cycle où
finissent des candidats de sic le pca en
95 donc en fait c'était
c'est un des tout meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux à ce moment là un cran en
dessous de kasparov
bien évidemment qui dominait à cette
époque mais mais voilà c'est un joueur
capable d'aller en finale le champion du
monde et donc après ce match 96 il avait
pris sa retraite qu'elle ait disparu il
avait passé dix clubs je pense de
l'avocat c'est ça médecin me semble
voilà l'autre en tout cas moi et on
aurait pu en disant quasiment et puis à
un moment il répond bien sûr des blés
les médecins médecin mais ça et il est
parti faire des tournois aux états unis
je l'avais repérée sur les vases aurait
attiré kembs qui rejoue et puis en fait
très vite parce que normalement fait tu
perds pas mal de niveaux avec l'absence
de pratique normalement dans le calcul
aux échecs est très important c'est un
peu comme un muscle que tu dois tu vas
travailler et qui va du coup tu muscle
pas trop pendant cette période mais
d'écouter les terres perdues et ils
avaient tous les tons et les lits qui
s'étaient qualifiés pour un match contre
topalov donc qui est un champion du
monde film on s'était pas estimé pas
qu'un peu compliqué expliqué qu'il y
avait deux champions du monde en même
temps
etc etc mais mais ça c'était pas son
problème en fer et en parallèle une
finale je suis la démo à ce moment-là
2008 je pense qu'ils avaient perdue
qu'elle ait perdu donc il a perdu deux
fois en finale le champion du monde mais
ces paradis arrivé deux fois c'est pas
juste une fois le hasard la chance c'est
deux fois ça commence à vouloir dire
quelque chose être un peu significatif
sm on appelait on les appelait les trois
cas les reins kasparov et karpov kamski
il a pu être 4 avec chroniques année
c'était un cra bon ben khalifa laquelle
il met sa main face à tarbes 15 7 6
d'ailleurs un petit peu caruana
même si l'orthographe n'est pas la même
peut-être que par oui ça dépend de
l'alphabet après mais donc caahc notre
spécial en cyrillique
c'est un creux en fait oui enfin je sais
que ça se montre en fait c'est juste à
bien m ça ressemble à un studio elle
écrit en minuscule ça ressemble à un x
mais qui s'est re donc rallye man ray
comme risma touline s'est maintenu à
toulon va prononcer qui sema touline
voir assez connus en fait c'est risma
touline mais c'est n'être simplement
différente fabien qu'on ne connaît pas
en tout bon chez nous dans un alphabet
qu'on n'a pas non pour ça qu'on fait le
fameux k h
je ne peux pas me demande la
prononciation le csaj par hamon vient de
prononcer parce que c'est le genre de
son qu'on n'a pas chez nous et qui sont
très durs pour les étrangers à lancer
correctement mais c'est un genre de
records une somme à crotone et c'est à
dire alors là oui mais sans m ouais
c'est un peu comme un chat ce tu touches
à 7 ans et cette envie quand même de
l'agression quoi qu'est-ce que le
vertueux pendant la pause on se jette un
oeil aux partis qui et les autres mâles
juste comme ça en accéléré on aurait
vite fait après 1 mais oui je me
souviens info ce juste après que ce qui
est intéressant
bon vous avez la fameuse victoire de
vichy il ya quarante années qui a gagné
contre de sa bête noire wang hao on le
regarde on accélère et du coup on
regarde vite fait jardin avec l'énorme
écart mc fait un gros tournoi trois sur
trois quand il était là quoi c'est pour
ça qu'on l'a sorti bas il est trop fort
pour le faible trop fort du coup tu ne
joues pas tu as gagné trois parties pour
le moment peut-être qu'il a un contrat
on n'a pas joué plus de ça c'est en fait
c'est ce que je vous dit que peut-être
les joueurs ont un contre un et il faut
respecter le contrat je jouis ajoutant
deux parties où on te certifie qu'il en
joue et en ont pas de sortir à chaque
ronde parce que tu joues mal en diable
faut bien de faire jouer je sais pas
ressasser possible aussi la jeu
j'étais pas je vais pas acceptent ces
infos de première main de dire oui c'est
déjà bien pour le foot c'est devant les
pions bien comme il faut
la torah coulisser sur le 6ème ranger
direction de droit elle en fait tu as
fait une démonstration une grosse grosse
grosse farce est sensible et est donc
dommage pour la stasi parce que les
chinois je pense c'est la première fois
qu'ils doivent perdre une partie sur un
échiquier tout en main et pourtant il ya
eu quand même le match hyper pendjab au
final non ces événements rares s'en va
pas arriver très souvent qu'il fallait
vider pour les états unis et ils ont
raté cette opportunité et peut-être s'en
mordre les doigts pour l'instant du
sacrifice de qualité tout non mais
franchement c'est une partie que je
pourrai reprendre pour une master class
1 m'impressionnait impressionnante à
neuf du roi l'âme du fou la tour sur la
sixième en marge et le g5 y va il a il a
cumulé les coûts de classe mondiale
ouais non il a été impressionnant et la
petite ta petite finale gâche rien mais
non il a été impressionnant fabiano
devrait lui assurer du coup peut-être il
ya un contrat alors ça ça pour expliquer
les choix bizarres des entraîneurs je
joue un bon sur deux si la pâte qu'on
soit comme ça où on à court
d'explications
ouais donc il est 16 heures 35 fabien il
reste encore 25 minutes de pause
s'alimenter
je ne sais pas c'est quand même des
longues pauses c'est vrai que j'ai pris
un fou rire tout à l'heure mais c'est
vrai que ça c'est reste quand même assez
étonnant et les échecs reste là dessus
quand même une exception un fabien web
c'est vraiment le jeu en soi pas changé
mais le format la cadence le pape soit
ce serait ça serait pas mal de reprendre
non mais une pause entre 15 et 30
minutes ça ça ça parait 38 déjà beaucoup
mais mais là on va arriver à 40 à 37 38
minutes de pause surtout qu'il faut voir
que c'est par rapport aux dernières
parties qui a terminé donc la plupart
des joueurs en plus de 48 de pause sans
les gens mais le pommier chill et bien
fun il semble aussi que 15 20 minutes de
pause ça suffit quand même assez
inquiets quoi là-bas surtout qu'il n'y a
que deux partis dans la journée parce
que c'est sûr si tu accumules temps et
déjà huit partis jouer sciemment tu peux
souffler un peu aller faire un tour te
détendre les gens de dégourdir ça te
fera du bien permettra de souffler et
d'être être alerte mentalement mais là
en fait faire deux parties de suite ça
va c'est un peu plus trop trop trop le
monde je pourrais comprendre mais mes
deux vous êtes apparemment peut-être
qu'ils ont tout ce monde parce que du
chat je ne sais pas comment tu l'as bien
de mon côté mais c'est possible que je
me rapproche et carole écrivait sur son
stream hier qu'ils avaient reparti le
nombre de parties équitablement entre
les joueurs côté américain ok bangalore
alors du coup il ya quoi il ya huit
partis de qualif c'est ça dix disent
ouais donc papa croit joueurs oubliés
par quatre joueurs il partit de quelques
fois 3 fait 30 parties et son rêve de
toute façon il y aura bien quelqu'un qui
joue un peu plus parce que 30 c'est pas
un 4,38 de 4,36 par meetic de 4 je crois
moi je vois mon nom mais tu vas 28 32
ans avait requis en a un qui j'aurai une
partie de moi donc j'ai utilisé
je croise une partie de moi
personnellement ouais mais apparemment
c'est pas parti pour à moins qu'ils
veuillent mettre à leur équipe de fous à
la fin bon bien mais tu as plus de
pression j'aime bien essayer de bien
partir et au cas où après bâti qualifié
au bout de sept journées et bah voila je
jouais amusez vous détendez vous plutôt
que de jouer à quitte ou double avec
avec si un mauvais résultat une partie
du tour de marc leiba divination c'est
beaucoup plus difficile dans ce sens là
on va le faire équitablement
normalement tu fais jouer la meilleure
équipe possible point bas en fait ouais
bah oui pas tu fais tourner comme ça
tourne j'en ai un qui est vraiment pas
en forme bien tant pis tu feras pas
voilà aussi demande à sortir parce qu'il
est fatigué ou pas ce qu'il va jouer
contre un mec qu'on qu'il ya des mois
résultats en avait un il ya plein de
raisons peut-être mais mais de décider à
l'avance quatre jours avant c'est à dire
bon bah on va faire ça à ce moment là tu
vas me manquer de souplesse et de
justement de l'activité au moment où
c'est important de bien choisir
mayence était étrange j'ai du mal à
comprendre l'idée de l'équipe américaine
là dessus fabien après ils ont dû se
mettre d'accord avant un bal chinois ils
sont que là pour gagner ils vont pas
faire ce genre de calcul d'apothicaire
noël chinoises sont ils jouent à fond et
une équipe européenne non plus
puisqu'ils n'ont pas du tout fait sortir
maxime non il y avait eu cette histoire
de nombre de partis qui table maxime
serait forcément déjà sorti un jeu soit
maxime où les vendeurs les deux qui joue
pour l'instant toutes les parties oui
maxime et les vannes qui vous tous et je
pense pas qu'il fasse sortir ni l'un ni
l'autre un cari guiry pourrait il
pourrait juste ne plus rejouer un moment
donné ouais où tu as une petite journée
changer les esprits parce que bon bien
sûr ça très fort joueur mais plein c'est
quand peut-être pas en confiance déjà
toujours mal aux échecs c'est comme ça
ouaip les idées claires tu réfléchis
plusieurs faux même variante jeu bien
sûr tu as un peu peur tu joue plus
libéré et ça se ressent et puis bajus tu
veux pas trop bien alarmant
et cette confiance faux l'arganier alors
souvent ça peut être lente et rapide ça
dépend des joueurs du genre très très
bon pour rebondir
non car rien on l'a vu perdre dans des
tournois à des lendemains sortir une
grosse partie n'a d'autre justement qui
sont meurtris par une défaite qui le
vivent très mal et qui vont essayer de
faire nul le lendemain de trois jours de
suite pour avoir le temps de se remettre
ça dépend des caractères mais mais là
comme ça je pars à québec en plus tu
peux sortir finalement refaire une
journée à soufflé ça peut aussi être la
bonne solution
après plus beaucoup de journées 1 si tu
souffles demain en fait 13 samedi battu
samedi ou pas est vite et on te fait
jouer pour la finale on peut te motiver
à fond à dire vas-y prépare toi à fond
tu vas jouer contre je sais pas quel
genre de chine passe quasi garantie été
prise et la tue un peu commun j'ai plus
qu'à l'euro ou studio situé au handball
quand l'équipe de france il y avait à
cambrai qui allait des remplaçants tout
le long même il est peut-être même pas
joué du tout et je pensais pas encore
sonné stoll le sélectionneur qui le
chauffer à fond les amis la demi-finale
tiens toi prêt à prêter nos prêts et
rentrer contre l'espagne à la mi-temps
email 8 buts ou quoi ils et cartonne et
en fait c'était une machine dans ce
match mais en fait ils avaient un
objectif il était préparé à fond pour ça
mais je crois que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile dans un mas compétition
individuelle parce que parfois il peut
en fait ces mets tes partenaires mais la
c1 mais bon sa descente de partenaires
non mais ma nouvelle boussole mais je
gagne tous alors je pense c'est plus
difficile de faire ça aux échecs tu as
tellement besoin de confiance je pense
que c'est bon quand tu sors à tout
jamais de la compétition tu refais pas
re rentrer pour la finale à mon mail non
mais c'est vrai que la vente
je lui dis je te sors mais prenant mais
l'a fait de même il a fait trop joué
déjà pour faire ça mais il a il y fait
que des défaites fait que des mauvaises
parties là c'est dur va être si si je
sais pas il fait nul dans une partie
correcte mais pas trop mal ou quoi mais
là en fait tu le fais fait la paire du
pm contre amine ben hassen fin on a dit
que c'est un joueur fantasque ou quoi
mais c'est un joueur qui est quand même
loin du top 30 top 40 mondial et il
s'est quand même pris une grosse
cartouche en une nouvelle fois mais bel
et bien sûr alors si tu avais une fois
comme conserve tous les jours
ouais si c'était que cette partie là ou
quoi mais là c'est pas je crois que ça
fait juste trop en réalité déjà pour
pour geri vers ce genre de stratégie
puis il sort aussi d'une compétition de
magnus invitationnal catastrophique mais
je dois ce dernier s'est fait avant
dernier ou quoi mais il a perdu tous ses
matches sauf enfin mathias effet
beaucoup à un moment donné ont besoin
bah ça veut dire que sur ont alors
appris la peut-être gagné une partie ou
quoi mais en gros sur teddy dernier
match à neuf défaites une victoire
oui c'est pas la forme de ta vie on va
dire un temps c'est comme ça le relancer
sur une finale
ou alors tu lui dis tu joues tel parti
compte telle équipe mais pas la finale
tu essayes de le relancer genre samedi
premier match un match moins responsable
tu relances mais bon il reste plus assez
toujours pour sa déjà battu le relance à
une journée de la fin
non je me suis fait juste sortir et puis
tu le renvoi plus puis c'est tout tant
pis pas de blessure d'un joueur mais
claquage du droit de la souris ni toi
non mais c'est pas grave je vous paye
vous par un bain blessure empire de
toute façon c'est comme ça après c'est
la loi va force de pas performé je
trouve que la partie là avec les blancs
il a perdu une partie mais très
facilement
c'était contre la chine mais petrov
il a rejoué avec les blancs contre je
sais plus qui je fus quelle équipe
s'était mais il s'est fait annuler mais
alors y perd facilement il a absolument
rien tenté c'est juste fait sécher sans
avoir le moindre
espoir de bien avoir deux gains après
contre sow avec les blancs il a un petit
avantage la sortie de l'ouverture il
s'est juste fait dominer et après il a
réussi à faire affaire nul mais cela
dominer et hélas il a de nouveau les
noirs et il repère mais il se reprend
une cartouche et il n'a jamais menacé à
quelques monde que ce soit de gagner une
partie même nom mais cela c'est un peu
too much mais c'est trop lassés trop fab
il a eu trois plans un noir du coup si
ma mémoire est bonne mais bon il ya
peut-être tué 2 et 2 mais en tout cas il
n'a jamais menacé de gagner en vue d'un
bookmaker rien illégale entre sausset
sur blanc votre souhait de finale mais
bien de la partie
il a eu le peuple en trois alors il a eu
une oreille alors il a rappelé que trois
parties il a loué la rampe 2 et il a
perdu aussi les clés blanc oui il est à
deux défaites une partie - et ça ça je
vais rajouter nul mais c'est ça c'est
j'ai confondu avec une partie de duda
mais ouais donc mais avec les plans les
deux plans ou il a encouru une hyper
sans se battre et l'autre il est un peu
dominé et la noire
la partie avec les noirs il se fait
déchirer c'est quand même ça ne permis
de le faire rejouer les coiffes injuste
au bout d'un moment il après fait il
ménage avec et parce que enfin en plus
c'est censé être un joueur solide femmes
mais le savons tu te dis bon bagheri il
va taper un nom plus c'est pas le profil
de gala doute à où tu te dis oui mais on
a perdu deux mais c'est son style il
peut se refaire là c'est un gars ils
rament pour gagner une partie non mais
on en même temps enfin c'est tout belga
on ne voit plus et puis c'est tout enfin
voilà ou alors si on est vraiment sûr
d'être qualifié avant la dernière ronde
alors on le fait rejouer pour un match
qui compte pour du beurre quoi voilà
comme ça tu fait souffler les autres oui
non mais tu le gardes que si un joueur
je te dis j'ai besoin de souffler faris
est un vrai remplaçant en fait c'est pas
un gars qui fait rentrer par plaisir
bien sûr bien sûr monsieur ferrasse qui
donne ce qui donne ce guéri tu penses
gary alors il fait l'équipe type là pour
le match importantissime contre la
russie de toute façon depuis le début il
a jamais mis deux fois de suite la même
compo est ce qu'il a fait depuis le
début aussi ce qu'il a tout le temps
laissé maxime et les vannes
donc si ça suit la logique il y aura
maximo prochain chiquet levano de duda
ou 3 et à naplouse et choco 4 je te dire
que les kamas en train de s'allumer que
je serai bien aboutie choco 4 1 ça
paraît pas juste s'était dit très
visible en fait un peu l'effet reçoit
donc oui mais non c'était sur la seule
question c'est c'est ce qui sort les
bonnes bon
plus rien c'est ça le jour qu'il y en
est à trois victoires tu ne te gagné
trois matches pour féliciter on va te
sortir on habitue doigts de l'essai mais
bon sait-on jamais sait-on jamais mon la
chine je crois que s'il gagne le
prochain match l'a déjà fait
mathématiquement non mais alors rien ça
a commencé
ils ont en fait tous finir premier ou
deuxième
ils ont déjà quatre points d'avance donc
deux victoires d'avancé sur sur les sur
les 3e et je pense qu'ils ont un bon
goal avérage aussi donc ouais les
chinois mais juin s'assemblent 500 se
dessiner un mais les favoris de
l'épreuve 1,12 façon alors passez le
pédiatre ont forcément gagné puisque la
finale se joue sur un match sur un match
pas toujours des surprises mais en tout
cas qui se qualifie pour cette finale
crise dans les deux premiers et sur un
conditions du match je pense que là il
n'aura pas black quoi après une finale
ça se gagne
sa semaine où ça se perd ça dépend pour
qui
mais non avec les chinois on l'a dit il
n'y a pas de point faible il ya un gros
point fort sur le 4ème et chicken et
après justement du coup ça peut jouer
entre guillemets un peu sur une partie
tu es surprendre sur ton point fort ce
qui peut toujours arriver
mettez ça peut être pour ça que sur une
finale tu peux perdre qu'il a dominé de
la tête et des épaules la compétition
alors voilà il suffit d'une gaffe de
woody fans jouent à une joute suivant
qui jour au quatrième et a le match les
toits qui suit bien le top 14 par
exemple ça arrive souvent que l'équipe
qui a bien dominé souvent régulière d'un
caracole en tête se fait un chemin en
finale outre et ce pour cinq sixièmes
qui passer par les barrages et souvent
pas très souvent ça arrive ça peut
arriver mais du coup les équipes qui
jouent les barrages en plus elles sont
sous pression un peu plus tôt et des
fois il arrive plus chaud pour les
demies donc déjà un risque en demi et
après en finale c'est la finale enfin
ces messages jeudi fermée aux échecs
c'est pareil une finale ça joue
différemment d'un autre match nadal un
peu a plus la passion en fait un cas que
ça va transcender donc ça va inhiber
c'est partout pareil
oui c'est ça joue différemment donc tout
peut arriver pour une finale car nous
écrit dans le chat c'est fréquent que
l'équipe qui gagne le championnat ne
gagne pas le brennus au est très
fréquent après rugby se trouve que la
phase finale ces six équipes
c'est pas un contre un il reste cinq
équipes à battre entre guillemets là ce
sera un contrat en finale mais tout de
même
après il y aura un avantage cette équipe
compétition à finir devant
c'est que match nul tu remporteras la
compétition c'est vrai que ça c'est un
gros gros
ouais mais mérité un jour eh bien non
mais oui mais alors pareil c'est à dire
que gros avantage mais ça peut te donner
envie de jouer avec le frein mais pour
tenir le 2 2 et enfin tu vois on va te
faut arriver à jouer normal et qui est
de dos plié mais ça c'est tellement dur
tu es peut pas vraiment faire
abstraction du contexte
alors pour le moment il ya trois joueurs
qui ont la cams et duda les bonnes et
anna et la question alors ça va être de
savoir est-ce qu'il ya maxime ou voir si
à maxime ou pas alors si aguerris à la
place de maxime je comprends plus rien
mais bon on ne demande qu'à être surpris
un castelet c'est comme ça j'ai deux
écrans l'acheteur je peux casser un
écran dès 20h40 s'alimenter alors quand
est-ce qu'on a déjà peut-être les
compositions ça arrive d'oublier de
regarder parfois avant les exams ra moi
j'ai pas sur mon côté
alors je les ai et c'est bien maxima qui
sera titulaire gic
quand on est pauvre mais vous sera très
près artemiev et béria keane qui rend
donc y avait pas joué le premier match
contre nous non il me semble non il n'ya
que les agneaux m breaking away il avait
andreikin tiens d'ailleurs perdu contre
éoliennes nouveau 4 encore mode sondages
qui la normale un ça allait vraiment
populaire alors qu'il ya vraiment un
gros écart est née peau alors est ce que
bon à prendre parce que revanche jamais
ce qu'on va en tilt on sait négocier
tout voilà quand il ya enfin billets
dans l'eau il peut battre tout le monde
il peut gagner des gros seins
alors quand il se met à mal jouer y'a
plus personne
ces tremplins il a la partie d'avant
est ce que justement il va être là à
môtiers où ça va être le nez pour des
mauvais jour qui va tout jouer tempo
sans réfléchir un coup et on va voir
mais atteindra quoi faire contre lui
tout cas attention parce que 6 ie6 la
russie perd ce match ils sont vraiment
quasiment éliminée ce que deux victoires
de retard sur quatre matches ça peut se
faire mais il leur reste la chine en
plus puisqu'elle ses débuts la phase
retour
donc il reste toutes les équipes à jouer
on peut enterrer l'équipe de russie avec
ce match mais elle dans leurs compos les
russies un truc j'ai pas qu'elle trouve
juste étonnant personnellement c'est que
cariatides sur leur blason ou au travail
doit être plus logique de mettre bon des
po1 c'est normal c'est devenu un
meilleur joueur ayant 4 mondial et quart
yakine au 2 août à août à 1 et pau
quitte dakar et qui de fait loin qui
peut jouer le joueur justement par de
faire car pas et tu as ton artemiev o2
et andré qui no 3 et les savants mais là
le problème c'est que si tu sors dépôt
c'est artemiev loin qui en voir un peu
léger pour aller jouer des joueurs comme
maxime quoi je pense et il découvre
cette non verte ou ta compo quoi on va
récupérer maxime sur la caméra
alors il user qui demandent s'il ya des
récompenses financières cette cup
oui oui il y en a et c'est pas mal
répartie d'ailleurs ses terres toutes
les équipes vont être récompensés
équitablement et il y aura que les deux
finalistes qui justement quand même
auront un peu plus mais mais toutes les
autres équipes comprend touché quelque
chose ouais ils auront 24 milles de plus
pour l'équipe gagnante et 12000 pourra
le finaliste donc et de base et ses
auteurs que je suis une super je suis 3e
aux derniers au point de porte alors du
coup il ya 180 36000 ya 144 milles à se
partager entre eux et les six équipes
donc ventes d'un peu plus haut vous
effectuez pain et 140 cas lisez par 640
qui a déboursé 25 millions 24,4 me 25
fois ci ça fait 150 et du coup ça fait
vingt-quatre s'est mis sous pression
petite révision de calcul monteur le
joueur français qui est en difficulté on
attend
il ya to kiss des quatre qui se
recadrent qui ce machin c'est pas
évident parce qu'ils sont en train de
montrer leur appart
on va repartir comme ça et on verra
après ils font tourner leurs pièces mais
pour bien montrer quelle personne pour
tous fait les coûts ou des choses comme
this way s'est passé soit ça soit pour
un promoteur immobilier peut-être si
elle est validée très heureux de montrer
son appart est super c'est un parent de
partout ce qu'elle compte bien comme il
faut et un bel appart la paix naïve bah
c'est beau quand on peut voir les
apartés tout ils sont bientôt la part
des joueurs en général que tu as pu voir
on évoque sa valeur très très doux tels
les bonnes techniques allant surtout
regarder les bonnes en fait c'est un bal
afin d'y plus les autres j'ai pas trop
regarder ça c'est anna ça c'est les
bonnes mal cadré ça c'est même bon
écoutez c'est vrai que par elecam un
petit peu mieux
1 1 qui va voir les blancs elle va un
petit peu souffert j'ai à conduire la
chine à l'heure de la première partie
mais elle est arrivée à faire annuler il
est donc là avec les pièces blanches
elle décide d'être un petit peu la
pression mais si elle fait toute façon
matches nuls c'est pas un mauvais
résultat du dos donc d'un grillage qui
naquit qui était finaliste du dernier
championnat du monde en a parlé il ya
deux jours perdus contre le chou wen jun
y est ce qu on a les apparences vendée
autre match tient juste par curiosité
par curiosité complètement alors les
chinois qui met diglee rennes i et du
yang edonkey qui continue à tourner et
jouer john woo qui tournait même à mes
yeux encore se comprendre ils sortent
congo qui a perdu et will find jouait
johnny je crois qu'il faut vraiment tout
en assurant
on va entendre et à
et l'autre ya à nantes visite d'abattage
et l'américain seth green team
ouais contre les indiens alors ils ont
pris peut-être le parti de ça fait bien
contre la chine disant que fallait
vraiment ap l'inde
ok mon nom va falloir assurer
aïe sirat les indiens la série que ça
leur fait mal hein mais c'était très
compliqué le match aller pour les uns
les autres sinon c'était la finale que
caruana a gagné avec lycée de jupons de
lecavalier c'était super l'on est bien
arrivé mais c'était pas c'est la finale
qui a fait repousser les horaires de la
thermie de la deuxième mandat ailleurs
le tournant mais c'était dû tourner en
patience a déjà un quart d'heure de jeu
soit déjà fini pour sa déjà un quart de
ses yeux qui ont repoussé
c'est un peu le le majlis nerf de cette
compétition oui ça vous en faites que
wimbledon du coup ils fassent un jour
non on ne joue plus le mardi parce que
si jamais il ya de nouveau à maylis nous
allons voir un jour sur deux ça serait
beau droite bien sûr comment il ferait
bien sûr et ce n'est pas tout le temps a
de tennis comme sa saison sur terre
battue
oui bon il ya vu clément santoro à
roland garros il ya trois mois quand on
ne sait jamais un match peut durer deux
jours montrent un match où les six jours
quoi après tu dois bien te reposer comme
il faut ça serait beau non j'ai pas
croyez toujours heureux de ces cinq là
bas fait vraiment comme ça qu'ils
pensent quoi pour moi c'est ça qui est
beau c'est vraiment comme ça qu'ils
pensaient
c'est vraiment comme ça qu'ils pensent
main c'est drôle c'est drôle d'un drôle
alors des coûts devrait pas trop tarder
un 16h58
oui ça va reprendre
niven qu'il ya un truc à temps expliqué
l'un d'eux maxime du coup ça c'est un à
suivre par la caméra de maxime attend
bon sinon pour les iphone
non mais là m c'est pas très difficile à
faire et on va mettre la caméra de
maxime
à la place le petit verre de jus de
pomme à une fois pas encore fermé et que
toi qui es bon ben je vais vous dire
donc si vous êtes jus de pomme ou à
petit et on ne sait pas on ne sait pas
comme ça on a maxime et greek food ne
joue pas à lens avec l'équipe de russie
est quand même un peu affaibli par par
l'absence de grille mais il faut dire
qu'il vous parle non plus les olympiades
tankers qu'est ce que bon les walter de
fait il les a pas joués cette fois il a
déjà augmenté très très souvent sont
tombés mais ce que là c'était compliqué
pour les jouer sur internet comme
camille née de père de famille c'est pas
pareil c'était les enfants tapent à une
pièce froide bien tranquille ou quoi
peut-il se sentait pas jusque là pas été
sélectionné que ça j'en sais pas mais
donc oui la russie gros vivier de
joueurs et c'est là qu'ils peuvent se
passer de getxo qu'alors ils peuvent se
passer c'est difficile et le mais ils
ont quand même des joueurs très
compétents pour mettre à la place il y
aura d'autres joueurs à plus de 2700 on
peut penser à soi même à iakovenko cas
peut-être plus de 1700 des taux machette
qui vit tube aph vite yougov ils sont
tellement nombreux
tellement gros séjour à russe en fait tu
peux même tu préfères nord-niger russie
2 qui serait moins strict du lendemain
oui pas battu mais très gris chucky
maîtresse vide l'air tue mais très vite
yougov ne peut m'être fait 2 cf qui est
pas un peintre empire voilà voilà
jaden de l'équipe ouais t'as tomaszewski
comme tu le disais iakovenko à et enfin
tu peux peut-être même faire une
réussite roy était arrivé est double
l'autre avec c'est une clôture et un
rideau la tomate la coff tu vas te dis
ouais c'est non mais en russie par
est-ce que ça a démarré pas encore 17
heures une grosse faute à rio mais moi
alors attends je crois que ça y est en
train de partir
allez c'est parti avec une carreaux
cannes pour un maxi milan ac le pion
c'est que d'une seule case cette fois ci
un mail avait joué à la main stream
capin il avait joué à la brigade
non c'était pas une prairie de la joue
aussi mais je sais qu'il a déjà levé
sans 2013 lors de la coupe du monde 2013
il avait déjà joué slavka rocade ils
attendaient ils allaient à mios mis à la
cave pendant sept ans et là ça ressort
est ce que tu pense qu'il va y avoir une
iapp à il n'y a pas eu le h4 pas idiot
de matthew par m il ya plein de bonnes
lignes ça peut te le h4 peut être le cas
il s'est rangé 4 ça c'est la ligne
classique qui a été mis à la bonne dose
et 90 par nigel short et gagne plein de
partie un jour comme ça et en irlande
placée simple et sa popularité et c'est
juste devenu elle la manière principale
pour le blanc de lutter contre l
ouverture avant justement les blancs ils
jouaient pas l'avoir davance mais plutôt
aux qualifs sait trop quelle idée de au
troisième pour défendre
jours il a réussi à prendre de court ses
adversaires oui bonne poignée de pays et
donc ses singles ça ressemble à une
française avec le fouquet pas ses plans
donc c'est ça que c'est un des coups les
plus agressifs parce qu'il ya plein de
joueurs sont à cannes qui retarde ses
pouces et 5 pour plus tard ont d'abord
se développer neobe le roi et donc ses 5
tu va au clash tu peux jouer d'amd 6
après pour l'attaqué les pions mais les
blancs de faire un truc comme seka
peut-être un moment où justement te
laisser b2 et voilà tu vois et ça va
être très compliqué il ya beaucoup de
toi genre qualifié 3-2 b2c une option
comment ça se passe mais c'est théorique
c'est ce qu'on vous disait tout à
l'heure je vous disais quand c'est
quelque chose de théories qui a été
analysée faut pas faire trop attention à
la jauge à gauche parce que ça peut
aller en fait parce que ça a été
analysée beaucoup plus profondément que
par un simple ordinateur qui regardent
en direct mais quand même ça une petite
indication à partir du milieu de jeu
plutôt rigolote nage donc du coup j'ai
d'hommes baissier s'esquisse il faut
débloquer a fléchi nepomniachi qui
réfléchit fois ce coup mais je crois
vraiment de mémoire que les blancs en
général sont très heureux de laisser son
pion b2 et comme on l'a vu un peu dans
la partie précédente donc de maxime tu
donnes un pion mais tu prends un
avantage de développement c'est un peu
esprit esprit garde temps à voir on va
avoir en tout cas c'est déjà une petite
bonne nouvelle qu'ils fassent réfléchir
nepomniachi ici bah oui on va être
déposée schiste c'est sûr qu'il connaît
mais encore faut-il se rappeler toutes
les analyses qui peut aller très très
loin
et en fait je sais pas si tu te souviens
une partie de karwan 1 contre maxime oui
avec un g4 un moment ouais bah c'est
celle de maxime toi qui a déjà dédié à
nice qui a peut-être mis à jour et tout
ça est donc tu vois quand tu en es
pasion si compliqué que ça
si t'as pas réalisé depuis un petit
moment vite être en bois
et donc quand c'est comme ça justement
tu peux à fléchir et pas joué le coup
que tu sais être le meilleur est
principal mais une petite ligne dont tu
es sûr tu te dis ok je sais que c'est
pas le meilleur mais on va pas de
mauvaise surprise et je vais pas me
confondre donc ça pourrait être un petit
rock pour lire une bêtise sur sa voix la
rampe ou b 3 j'en sais rien quoi en être
un mais trois jeux pas trop en faire non
mais il fût ce qu'à dit sûr que faith et
iii toute façon et sur calais ces toiles
semblent c'est d'abord calice et 6 pour
les noirs petit rat classement on peut
les prendre des deux et c'est compliqué
ouais donc la suite rappelle passé avec
ses positions qui peuvent être
accomplies tiers d'ailleurs et demain
juste trois expériences une fois je
savais que c'est les coûts pour les
blancs jouer comme ça je traversais
reconnaissait moi j'étais là pour moi
même et d'ailleurs je suis en tout cas
tiré d'un nul
non je fais nul mais c'est pas brillant
brillant bombe à voir en tout cas il ya
déjà pris trois minutes or c'est marrant
parce que c'est un joueur qui habituent
foot ou rapidement là il prend du temps
il est vraiment de prévisible en a et
déroutant imprévisible yann maximum s'il
continue à jouer rapidement comme le
veut le dire ne vous inquiétez pas sur
la jauge de gauche ça veut rien dire
pour le moment c'est théorique ce que je
joue à ce que tous les joueurs une
épaule et peu qui prend son temps et qui
sera peut être plus tout bêtement un qui
a du mal à se rappeler le pensons je
pense a ajouté trois minutes
ouais tu prend pas trois minutes comme
ça on en partie rapide dans l'ouverture
si tu sais ce que tu es en train de
faire c'est pas un ring il donne un
vague souvenir mais c'est très concret
très précise et inverse de coûts qui
joue pas dans le bon timing ce qu'il
faut et ça va plus du tout donc en tout
cas bon choix du coup de maximin qui a
surpris son adversaire
on dirait tintin c'est clair c'est même
pas combien c'est sûr qu'il a surpris et
donc maxime il connaît bien ce qui fait
et dans leur le joueur russe un peu
bur qui doit travailler au moins sa
mémoire vous cherchez à dribbler la
préparation adverse et sait jamais si
j'avais un sentiment agréable d'être
direct sous pression alors que tu
attendais à être justement en contrôle
talent et blanc tu lui a dicté le jeu et
n'ont été pris à la gorge très vite we
rock ça paraît logique
c'est le coût normal c'est le coût
normal ici marocaine mais mais j'étais
en plein air peuvent aller peut-être
prendre b2 à ce moment là c'est vite
vite vite compliqué ouais s'éviter un
souci on va voir parce que roth d'un
premier de quoi dire ça attaque le
cavalier ça attaque le pion en c2 et si
tu t'amuses à jouer du calibre des 5
je crois que les 9,3 go comme si ces cas
donc tu peux les gagner à la qualité
enfin la tour pour l'instant mais ça va
être une qualité au final c'est un
cavalier il va jamais ressortir tu vas
perdre ses deux et puis puis en fait les
noirs c'est comme un peu d'avancé les
deux pions pour la qualité et puis ils
sont mus en fait ils sont menacés en
tout cas et du coup le cas les médecins
que c'est pas le coup nancy roc dames
prend b2 dame me défendre cavaliers
garde les options tourbe et un garde
légale et b5 peut-être pour plus tard
mais il est ainsi très compliqué parce
que les normes plein d'options parce que
déjà tu dois regarder est ce qu'il n'ya
pas le fouquet un bep cap de cloud etc
moi c'est donc un truc justement ma
partie que j'ai joué ou gt1
donc je tiens plus de rien il vaguement
la partie et il s'est compliqué quoi
jeter un verre s'était vite téléphone
guerre et willa du mae a pas rentrer
là-dedans qu'ici vous faire carrière à
carte du coup bas 5 et ses trois autres
bon ça pourrait jouer à mon avis ça va
tu vas pas perdre avec les plans tout de
suite alors il a décidé il a joué
cavalier à carte tu vois barrett ses
idées pu avoir il soumet fait voilà il
choisit de petit il ya un truc qui se
joue à bhl et il sait que c'est pas le
mieux
il est sarah mon avis la juge choisi de
jouer truqués n'en sais rien enfin non
mais y ou dans les baies de ça c'est sûr
qu'il n'en génère la cavalière quartier
pas l'impression qu'ils connaissent
beaucoup après on y va non juste il doit
savoir c'est d'être une option bec du
bus doit pas garantir grand chose
huit personnes le jour mais non c'est
pas plus que ça il sait jusqu'à 4
jouable et puis c'est tout puis voilà
puis on va jouer aux échecs
on ne peut pas faire un test de mémoire
on va juste du jeu et du coup mais donc
ce qui a valu à 4 attention un petit peu
hors jeu et pourra toujours avoir l'oeil
à un coup comme bessin quinze jours
ouais donc normalement tu auras une
cadence et cinq pompiers venus parce que
talent fou 3 qui veulent défendre mais
juste une erreur d'inattention tu parles
tu t'en fous tu te fait dévier t en
tdt soit en surcharge
ça peut ça peut dégénérer il ya deux
options et qui soit qu'il prend des
quatre direct et peut-être le trophée
qu'elle y pense et b4 bientôt qu'elle
promet car il faut prendre des deux mais
ça c'est leur truc typique des
françaises tu as déjà trois pions pour
la pièce allez place au 10e jeu direct
il a fêté un décalque été plus logique
et prend des quatre mais sûrement [ __ ]
enfin bon du coup voilà c'est ça sur un
coup comme des cinq ans ferme le
cavalier enfin on enfin - du tout parce
que il y aura qu alice et 5 il a par
contre c'est pas top pour pour les noirs
parce que ce cavalier d'ailleurs bond il
est bien placé on s'est fait des
faiblesses partout on n'a rien développé
il a donc fait carré de 7 6 pour les
noirs oui très bien l'idée du wti c6
ensuite sa part très très normalement
oui mais c'est plutôt une réussite et un
l'ouverture la wii non plus en fait quoi
faire d'autre parce que le truc c'est
que tu envie de développer ton fouet le
canal y es tu déjà pour vous
en tout cas c'est la gazette qui prend
la case du câble et ouais mais ça va
quand même sens les plus simples de
sortir la cavalerie mais de faire une
place aux fous match tout commence ici
à pâques des choses intéressantes au
centre on l'a dit lors du premier jour
et dans le 2e 2e jour hier on l'a répété
aussi l'important échec c'est de
contrôler ces casses centrale et ramener
le cavalier sur une case où ils
contrôleraient c'est c'est intéressant
pas complètement il ya en plus il fait
quelque chose de bien la balle clavier
c'est c qui colmate la diagonale ouverte
contre le roi c'est une des différences
sur la carreau cas dès l'ouverture
française c'est justement le chou il
sorti devant les pions donc
et évidemment il est beaucoup plus forte
plus actif mais il remplit pas ses
tâches défensives de défendre c'est bien
agréable qui est ouverte un donc un coup
de table qui arrive
pourquoi ça peut arriver par moment et
donc lorsque cavaliers qui vient me
blinde aiken sécuriser ce qui est rare
assure juste moi je vote sur la caméra
femme depuis tout à l'heure à la musique
ou qui se lève et qui sera sciée je suis
juste une curiosité de jeter un oeil sur
sa partie désolé saison lorsque les
pseudos à côté on s est marié à une
autre salle
c'est pas facile jeu mais non les
chamois se lever se rasseoir fin du coup
je me dis est ce qui se passe quelque
chose en x passe rien en fait non c'est
sur les positions comme les petrov ou
quoi bon la scène française des changes
mais ces cellules sont très symétriques
très égal ou non mais a rien à signaler
ras affamés bon juste est là elle se
lever de sa chaise sur un seuil est
celui qui fait ils formés dans les
jambes
ouais n'a été donné peut-être
l'impression qu'il était un sacrifice un
truc qui se calculent quelques jours et
qui te donne envie de te lever de teura
soir qua non mais à noter qu'en fait
dans les tournois en dur pour rien c'est
très fréquent que les joueurs se
baladent une faction joue un coup et
c'est pas juste pour regarder la lune en
fait tu peux marcher avoir l'échiquier
dans ta tête et tu réfléchis sans avoir
besoin d'être là regardez ce qui se
passe et la danse est parti sur l'ordi
justement les joueurs sont bloqués
devant l'ordi mais finalement de bouger
il ya d'autres choses s'arrangent pas de
réfléchir la position il y en a qui sont
même plus à l'aise qu'ils puissent mieux
comme ça alors née peau qu'est ce qui va
faire famille va faire du sras qui va
laisser
ces six qui va quand même avoir un souci
à se faire c'est quand le quercy ci peut
te prendre la paire de fou oui oui oui
c'est possible
bon après camping s'est pas non plus
fous de la nes de choux des quatre mais
ça peut parler à terme tout cas c'est ce
qui va se passer le prochain cru des
noirs cavalli ces six années pour il est
prévenu voilà sauf si il joue b4 et qui
chasse la dame mais sur n'importe quel
coût normal landa du genre petit recoux
quoi évidemment maxime va ramener ce
cavalier ans et 6 mai de pression sans
relâche en 2010 elle prépare un
développement du fou et gérard potier
rock comme ça l'harmonie sera totale
dans la collection noire ils auront
développé toutes leurs pièces leroy sera
à l'abri
et puis ils ont passé l'ouverture sans
encombre et sajoo 1 et saint geours
mesure après incident a mené trois
peut-être qu'il peut être une option des
marchés non je vais faire flouer
saint-justin me prend 8 mais je voulais
montrer foulée cinq des sept matches
pour illustrer et en tue par les noms
mais je vais sur dame bête il a fait
jusqu'à 3 ou ok bon c'est mon saint
cloud dont on parlait de caruana mais
chez nancy ça recommence mais bien plus
tard
sarko bien plus tard je vais dès le
premier coup des fois à l'arrivée mais
la voilà il va faire quoi il va faire
bouger et six skiffs le cartel 3 pas
très intéressant je vois pas trop
l'intérêt
parfois ça se joue mais là je te dire je
ne sais pas trop pourquoi on va le faire
mais en fait en même temps pourquoi je
vois pas de contre-indication potes si
vous le faites le fait je passerai le
fait pas voilà alors l'idée ça pourrait
être peut-être désir dans longtemps
quand qu'y avoir envie arrivant c'est si
si on prend des cas tout bois génial
pour être la fépie pourquoi pas sain se
paye au prix fort et uni il y aurait une
idée coillard x 4 après est ce que c'est
que de toute façon ce but mais bon après
dans le côté tu peux dire que le pion
inédit en france
protège le projet 4 c'est ça je vois des
avantages les intérieurs de coups et je
pense c'est pas évident de faire une
vraie idée de quel est le meilleur des
deux d'ailleurs ce sont les deux sont
jouables et plus ou moins légales valeur
donc adressé sa maxime doit décider
après conçu avec fuji si tu pourrais
peut-être khalid et joue avec h5 a fait
perception là émettre le cas pour
remettre le carignan f5
tu tu aurais moins 7 sél on tapera au tf
train ça dépend ce que tu veux faire et
il est parti pour fou j'ai six directes
qu'à rester cinq jours épargnés peau
donc sur bien d'autres c'est ok les
aubiétains maxime oui alors l'idée
simple c'est carré lisse et 6 km 5 alors
la haye et une faiblesse il
il est happé tubes ont sûrement clément
vont blindés ce pion avec l'option f
irait en f4 donc généralement d'avoir
fait froid si l'option est d'essayer de
toute façon aller en f4 ce sera
exactement la même position il aurait
juste un coup de jouer de plus bon ça
change pas grand chose ça peut avoir son
importance dans les parties lentes quand
on a un nombre de coups à jouer à boire
ajoutant d'une cadence clasico d'échec
c'est le 40 coups deux heures c'est à
dire qu'on a deux larges de cancun et
apprendre à un rajout donc à ce moment
là se rapprocher ce 40e coup c'est
important parce que ça fera un temps
plus importante pour être fier sur des
coûts importants et là par contre qu'on
est de 40 ou 60 ou 20 c'est la même
chose on a un temps imparti pour toute
la partie
donc ça changera voilà alors qu'est ce
qui va nous jouer les pommiers h et est
ce que tu joues f4 direct façon tu vas
devoir le jouer il va mettre le carré
les ans et 6 et après tu vois tu rock
même peut-être wemmel a prodigués pour
les cartons si on vous prend oui bon
apprennent que tu peux jouer encore à
quai ce christ option pour cinq points
des quatre je peux quand tu commencer
par damas quatre peut-être dernier le
roi justement jouer sur la faiblesse de
sa diagonale d'amd ce n est pas possible
à cause de fouilles b5 exactement
l'atrazine belle illustration de nu du
club se développe donc il sera obligé de
jouer wife fuite et peut-être fait
tousser en maintenant notre coup prend
des quatre dames seront des quatre jurés
nakajima pas tendre
non mais cette position là est un v6 est
un v6 et à tour ses cinq pour interdire
les changes est d'abord là les blancs
seraient mieux ou lisa je peux échanger
pour ses sets c'est quand même quand
même très désagréable point où même
d'échanger absinthe dire mais oui selon
ses katas ok c'est pas simple donc mais
on peu rauque et sans avoir peur de
perdre ses pions ok rock c'est un autre
coup ça pourrait être des quatre pour
bien stabilisé le cavalier s'il se fait
chasser il recule et ça tient tous voilà
ou même calibre et 3,10 à part avec
l'intention de reprendre d'un cavalier
en d4 qui serait quand même super
castres en cavale et c'est ce genre cas
ce qu'on aime pour un cabas nick c'est
un truc stable où il veut pas se faire
chasser facilement par action il est
bien défendu et il est centralisé ils
contrôlent donc plein de quel retour
donc ça c'est une bonne case mais du
coup les noirs je pense qu'il
faciliterait la vie des blancs en
échangeant il vaut mieux pas le faire
alors il a vu h4 ok bon bah je sens que
ça a l'air d'être du coup normal mais h4
oui parce que je trouve thomas alors
c'est peut-être un très bon coin mais à
première vue ce que je trouve dommage
c'est quand il fera f4 il ne sera plus à
f5 pour enfermer le fou aura la case h7
mais bon d'un autre côté et doit avoir
une autorité en maxi qui doit hésiter
entre 6 5 1 qui imaginent toujours où on
hésite toujours entre les deux en tout
cas c'est vital parce que les blancs
menaçait d'en faire une fouille par
contre directement par h55 sais je
trouve plus dans le style de maximin ont
vendu fils un pion mais tu te donnes la
case f5 advitam eternam main j'ai pas
trop aimé ce courage 4 à fabien moi je
trouve son parti sur 24 nous on va voir
parce que l'autre idée des normes c'est
usa hockey je vais clore au centre mais
peut-être faire tour g1 rendre difficile
la sortie du show et fuite et puis voilà
comme ça suffit les cistudes départ à
ses pions de roulettes à un vrai plan de
plus pourquoi votre face c'est ambitieux
ce qui fait des bonnes notes chine bien
sûr ça a des défauts mais pas que il ya
quand même des points forts avec ceux
avec cette idée maxime qui est toujours
en pleine réflexion
donc et b ouais pour sa du tour génère
du damas quatre d'amaga dans cinq ans
rock
sinon tu gardes ton romieu de phoebé 4
et eu plein de la passion ska noir tu as
plein plein plein d'options une fois
plus tu préfèrerais jouer avec qui non
les noirs parce que par mais ça c'est
plutôt par habitude de jeu ces
structures de défense française
mais bon tant que genre de leucate je
suis confronté avec les blancs donc ça
me déplaît à elle pas une partie un peu
compliqué comme ça pour aucune des deux
couleurs jaune et c'est intéressant il
ya beaucoup de déséquilibre un pion de
bus pour les noirs l'examen bras jambes
du coup mais bon et bien sûr paul & joe
très vite compliqué vite compliqué les
blancs ils ont à coup pousser leurs
pions ils ont quand même des trous
choses peuvent se passer dans les deux
sens les deux sens donc dur de voir un
club favori clair pour l'instant les
bonnes chez 12 heures et s'était shan à
china non celle là ça peut pas
équilibrer parfois c'est très équilibré
c'est la caméra qui marchent ils ont
changé la musique c'est comme ça se
prononce comme ça se fera pratique alors
ouais les échecs on a beaucoup de noms
des pays de l'est a toujours évident à
écrire même chez les commentateurs donc
cette position là c'était une française
des changes et ça joue pour la case de 5
mais la joueuse russe daria zilina qui a
réussi à bien placer ses pièces pour
contrôler cette case 5 et pour mettre le
carrier tête aussi vers f4 ces
pollutions vraiment équilibré symétrique
mais ça nous déplaît pas forcément
fabien sur ce 4ème nombre en gros quand
il est comme ça normalement si ça peut
ramener vers la news
si les deux genres seront pas d'erreur
c'est on le voit c'est moins un conflit
moins déséquilibrée clarté de maxime où
ça peut vraiment partir dans tous les
sens la plus simple à jouer pour les
deux joueuses mais c'est pas pour autant
que ces 46 à 100% après ce match nul
pourquoi est ce que je dis grillage qui
n'a à se prononcer
je pense les eaux et à en russe mais
s'il n'y a pas de stress dans le mot
normalement ça se pense plutôt à un
mariage qui n'a commença du stress nos
maux voilà normalement en fait ils
finissent pas le stress chez nous en
français est toujours à la fin le stress
dans un décor naturel
on insiste sur la lapidation attendre
d'accord et en russe ça dépend mais
c'est rarement la première syllabe
c'est souvent là ça doit être la
deuxième ou la troisième mais je
n'arrive jamais à le faire parce qu'en
france et on a le défaut de vouloir
appuyer les fins mais du coup
en premier comme ça au celui quasiment
fouras d'accord ça va plusieurs 2 h
suivant le mot fin c'est un peu
compliqué mais c'est trop compliqué le
cas le cash legault le 1er f et offre
aussi d'ailleurs
ouais mais du coup serait un genre de
carre h qui n'a en fait ils les russes
il prononcerait plus tôt à mais comme
c'est pas le l'endroit le plus important
du mot on l'entendrait pas trop quoi il
sera un peu mangé et donc du voyage qui
lance limite tower rush qui n'a pas trop
quand même bon sens n'est pas très
rustique lisa d'accord quand même moi ça
pique un peu les oreilles mais tu peux
le dire aussi
d'après ce que j'ai compris par la
russie est très grande et il ya des
régions de russie où les gens peuvent
parler un peu différemment ces genres de
d'accent de de patois locaux ou de brad
wall
et je crois qu'il ya des endroits où ils
lisent comme c'est en fait guère
efficace écologique est ok
tout est possible mais on veut
comprendre pourquoi tu me prends ça
comme ça c'est possible
bon alors il ya les pions doublé pour
vous ou qu des spams a clos ce qu'elle
fait parce que finalement les trous
qu'elle a créée c'est surtout que trois
ou quatre
l'option n'a fait que défendre mais les
kabyles sont très loin de cette case aux
quatre déjà pour français et le football
1 2 les autres casse donc de ce côté là
on est tranquille et donc à la
conception lé de quoi là pour ces tours
peut-être là se donner la case et 5 pour
y placer deux cavaliers un moment en
tronc qui petit trajet pour y aller et
voilà donc un projet et elle ne joue
donc pas pour faire juste nul sans rien
faire et tout est changé elle tente sa
chance
donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle on peut
aller voir les autres et cliquer pour se
faire un avis complet avec les bons
levon levon contre contre ladislav web
écoute
ce jour seule la santé sas
vous savez tout est ok j'avais peur xto
blanc je bafouille
l'idée c'est d'envoyer un seau blanc de
jeu il peut sûrement elle prendra
prairies qui a dit aux 5 est ce que
parce que sa taxe option compliqué et le
problème c'est quand le prenant donc
outre sa fait chaque nous attaquent la
tour ce serait une fourchette très
compliqué alors du coup peut-être qui
vas tu attends ok donc en fait je
comprends de ladislav viennent jouer le
coup ces cinq donc c'est un cinquième ce
document pour voir s'en fout il menace
est donc ce genre de coups de chypre en
f3 et caillau 5 ou fou prend la 3 qui
valait h4 même même idée installer de
l'attaqué f3 ok donc compliqué en fait
un tout peut se passer ici aussi c'est
peut-être mois at on dit chez maxim mais
ça peut s'enflammer
en fait c'est à les vannes de choisir
est-ce qu'il enflamme les débats mais en
prendre ce pion ou est ce qu'ils
essaient de garder plus le contrôle mais
par contre dans la troisième partie
c'est plutôt la bonne affaire pour les
européens puisque la pollution est
complètement dulin fabien il va rien se
passer ici c'est c'est clair et donc on
devrait faire du lac et pièces noires et
ça nous laisse ça nous laisse les blancs
c'est toujours pareil c'est ça donc
c'est plutôt bien s'est plutôt bien et
coûtent 12 heures qui nous fait son
tournoi quand même bah ouais c'est doux
le l'envi de plus faire entrer guérit
pas ce que tu peux pas le faire rentrer
à la place des nouvelles mvl s'il n'a
pas perdu une partie au premier il a
fait que des nuls mais c'est quand même
bien en soi et surtout qu'il a peut-être
un peu pressé mal bonne baguette au
l'évangile gagnent tout et et maxime et
à duda
il est bien plus fort que que guiry sur
ce tournoi donc ça ça devient difficile
de leur faire rentrer 1
on verra demain alors est ce que maxime
chattam b3 va décider tous les grands
rock fabien pour défendre le pion
bessette j'ai attaqué actuellement par
la dame se serait pas étonnant ce serait
pas étonnant parce que petit rock c'est
compromis parce que tout est ouvert là
bas il est déjà pu y aura six éditions
qui ont annoncé la colonne g ça fait
beaucoup d'arguments contre le petit
rock et donc bal rock semble du coup la
destination normale du roi pour pas de
cachet
est ce qu'un coup de trafalgar comme
carey ya six mois je pensais que c'était
prenable et roy 17 et qui sait si ça
prend donc c'était pour essayer d'en
fermer journois le brillant 17 je
voulais jouer ce que tu m'avais dit
faible mais car ayant ses six viendrait
au dernier moment colmatée exactement
mais bien sûr tarzo signaler ce genre de
coup complètement inattendus comme
cavalier à 6 août sacrifices ça peut
vraiment faire très mal à un moment ou
un autre il faut toujours très très très
vigilants et canards du kava les assises
du cac et prend bessette plus qu'elle
est jeune c'est zooey vous prend à 7
oui c'est dangereux ce pas dire ça va
pas même ça a l'air d'aller plutôt pas
trop mal pour les noirs mais il faut
être très vigilant parce que les plans
ont quand même les pièces braquet et en
montre autour de se revoir après elles
peuvent se faire très vite chassé alors
que sergei cariat kiné et toutes ont
signé la nuit donc c'est officiel mais
si le cavaliere violence et 6 on
attaquera le fou on a trak rapion on
mettra le cavalier sous pression et
autant comme tu le disais à l'heure
actuelle c'est plutôt les pièces
blanches qui sont en nombre à l'ale
dames en revanche après qu'un mini c6
qui va vraisemblablement arriver ça peut
être même un défaut côté blanc puisqu'il
va peut-être falloir rapatrier tout le
monde
et oui donc le serait une perte de temps
mais je pense qu'à 4 il veut il veut
pousser à fond le pion allez allez allez
créer des brèches dans le camp adverse à
s'engouffrer
mais jeu très risqué de la part de
données pommier çi honnêtement ça me
pas perdre bon ça perd trop violent même
si quand bien même tu arrives en a6
alors attendez c'est pas grave
un joueur qui aime bien partir en fait
dès qu'ils ont fini leur parti qui
partent killzone
mais du coup ça aille vite car oui donc
est ici sa singulière c'est la partie ce
que je vais te montrer mais en fait
quand bien même je vais très bien si je
fais p6 et tu fais toujours pas grand
chose non c'est ça mais du coup la dia
battre encore plus affaiblie
vous venez un verbe et 5 et je ne sais
pas ce que tu en fait de spécial mais tu
essayé quelque chose peut-être qu'après
deux fois du tour c'est un essai
gâteries s'affaiblit face à des projets
la supérette hughes est pareillement
bessette et rebondir un jour voilà ici
ceci non mais tu vois je peux pas dire
c'est l'air un terrifiant
voilà tu as pu redescendre à calais
prend 2,5 c'est une option qu'on a envie
de regarder surtout prendre 5 on
pourrait pas reprendre cinq ans doit
prendre l'autre parce que l or et mat
et c'est vrai que si on prend ces 5
du coup à six ça peut commencer à faire
des troubles pour frapper 6 mai les cas
de mort justement sont un peu faibles
parce que le chou 107,6 bien de l'acca
rocade sortie et bat était moins bien
avoir vu la française en 17 langues
après je vois que l'ajout de
l'ordinateur donne un avantage aux
blancs mais honnêtement ça m'aurait pas
effrayer plus que ça non plus en fait
non aurait peut-être une menace comme
des quatre à dire où va la dame si tu
prend pratiquement 50 ans je veux dire
il te fait comprendre les sept îles et
revendre et capoue et il te joue sur la
légion passer de l'autre côté ça mais
c'est très long après c'est compliqué
parce que maintenant envoyer leurs pions
centre etc
mais euh ça à faire floquer prend 2,5 mg
et ont du coup tu peux peut-être as tu
fait dans l'autre sens vous avez il peut
prendre ça ils aiment bien du coup mais
voit un truc et je suis juste et honnête
à revoir la jauge noir plus plus avancé
dans cette partie bah le truc c'est que
déjà il ya camille pin que sur
l'allemand donc l'ordinateur qui
comptabilise ce matériel est
[Musique]
il ya une attaque potentielle peut-être
contre ce roi noir
donc c'est pas non plus mais bon ça peut
vite il va ça va vite mal se passer il
peut y avoir trop de bâtons ouais entre
de bâton peut être violent donc il faut
il faut il faut faire attention surtout
que à côté
naceri que quand y'a plus trois partis
ont tous permettent de faire des petits
flashs ça se passe plutôt bien côté à
nawa qui va presser petit à petit et
grâce à parier nul je vais dire mais
plutôt par le point et les maintenant
qu'est-ce qui donc il a il est pas les
gagner le pion il a joué plus tranquille
et on peut le comprendre
c'est très compliqué n'a plus tout peut
arriver non oui bien sûr que l'épisode
ce pur f3 viendra vers f4 moment et du
coup on va pas craindre de le perdre il
contrôle parmi les cases il à la seule
colonne ouverte de l'échiquier à sa note
est important mais l'os
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué ce qui se
passe mais je pense que pour l'instant
il coûte je vois pas d'échiquier où
l'équipe d'or et mal oui mais la partie
de maxime pourrait vraiment être
déterminant temps là c'est la position
la plus incertaine j'ai envie de dire où
ça peut vraiment tourner encore de
chaque côté les deux joueurs se rendent
coup pour coup et et c'est vrai que une
défaite de maxime mettrais nous
mettraient vraiment très en danger une
victoire nous mettrait très bien sur les
rails
parce qu'on a quand même l'impression
qu'on les deux autres parties se
seraient pas incroyable que ça finisse
par un partout en mai devon il peut une
nouvelle fois sur le sol on va voir en
tout cas partie de maxime forcément
déterminante à lui reste plus que trois
parties
et ce car il prend 1,5 et une option
pour prends je te reprends ta tour et là
on va maintenant des stock options et à
boen exactement exactement
il aborde ce toujours truc où il faut
faire un premier tri des quatre prix ces
cinq ans à ce qui me faisait peur à et
surtout c'est tout simple ou les gâteaux
c'est qu'à part attend ses chaudières
bois revient pour ça que je dis que ces
choix c'est pas ton c'est un rat des
cartes parce que ça
la dame robin 1 3 des 8 français cinq
dames des deux hommes ça c'est spécial
mais on a repris notre champ de moins
denses à ce niveau de rupture on n'est
pas trop mal
alors il a fait dépenser 5 comme
français 5 peu de cire hoc à loreley
rock mais les joueurs les lettres du mal
à attaquer parce que tu as 5 est tenu et
si tu fais ici s'il sera encore faire un
coup pour prendre ça peut être le berger
symbole mais de toute façon il faudra
beaucoup oui mais au moins tous vers la
colonne j'ai vraiment été un pion qui
supportera son attaque mais écoute
il joue très risqué dépend très très
très après il a peut-être tirer la même
conclusion que nous écoutent les russes
le match nul ne les intéresse pas là ils
sont ils sont en retard oui tu attends
on a déjà vu contre nac a dépassé les
bornes et finir par perdre un truc jeter
lui qui devait presser ou place à un
bernable et donc il peut refaire un
presse que je pense que le match nul ici
mais vraiment la russie option sûre ils
ont vraiment besoin de nous battre on
peut refaire un point sur le classement
parce que c'est c'est important mais si
tu si tu remets le classement fabien on
a sept points ils ont cinq points match
nul ils auraient toujours deux points de
retard ils n'ont pas un super goal
avérage comme tu l'a souligné ils ont un
peu forcé les matches et quand ils ont
perdu ils ont perdu sur des plus gros
score donc ils ont probablement plus
besoin de gagner que nous et il ya les
américains aussi dans l'équation pour
eux donc c'est une bataille à trois il
faut vraiment qui recolle et les peaux
qui parlent plus ils sont pas forcément
bien dans le match donc c'est vrai c'est
vrai il ya les vannes a fait mieux le
grand alors nul du côté des one aronian
on exactement en répétant les coûts doc
est bête ou peugeot sur maxime en fait
tout le jeu chez maxim et du coup and
away ce à des coûts de ces genres de
position quand même elle met une petite
pression mais ce serait pas délirant de
voir un hameau gichuki grillage qui n'a
fait un nul wayne carr est classé celui
de cannes où il avait déjà bien commencé
là tu as bien prononcé à l'histoire tout
comme tours à quatre pour être
intéressant oui c'est vraisemblable
qu'ils défendront pions qu'il n'y a
peut-être vers b 4 trains pression sur
le clan beissat donc tu multi usages
c'est intéressant ça c'est une
possibilité pour le joueur russe à 6,6
toujours une possibilité évidemment
pourquoi au tp 6 à mon avis va le faire
tôt au tard ce que nous souhaitons plus
réussi à 5
c'est quoi le progès c'est juste pour
perdre deux coups de temps avancé un
pion qui franklin il l'a fait
écoute il y est vrai il est en
réussissant rastislav ans a dû très
logique et c'est un danger permanent
en fait ce genre pions pour les mains
avec la dame qui périodes il apparut
comme sur la partie d'abord fait un
contrat non dépôt en est qu on vous
dirait du roi est aussi même cet habitat
8e en rangée pour les finales tu peux
voir des matchs du couloir qui traînent
tu peux avoir des super action à 7 le
plus ultra de gaz de dames donc c'est
c'est un danger long terme soit là pour
le coup on dit michel b seager essais
mais n'y a qu'à 6 pour une tour comme ça
c'est intéressant enfin ben oui mais là
non mais c'est à double tranchant dans
ses parties c'est risqué si fait mais
c'est loin d'être absurde entre
évidemment je peux te dire que les fans
au contraire au contraire de duda reste
pour pouvoir garder ses nerfs il regarde
la joie son écran c'est marrant mais ils
en train comme nous de regarder la
partie de maxime
il est comme nous en train de regarder
la partie donc les bonnes qui est
vraiment impliqué dans la compétition un
autre après doodle juste qu'il dise ou
mais regardons même winamp aussi mais
j'arrivais sap france duda dénote
quelque chose je dis pas que duda n'est
pas impliqué puisque l'on sait pas ce
qu'il fait mais je dis juste qu'il se
trouve que harmonia dévoilant des sûr
qu'il avait sur qui les regardent ils se
voient un peu d'eau ils y réfléchissent
à fait cette petite grimace il heureux
mais il est en plus il va être mettre sa
caméra il regarde concentré en plus ils
regardent vraiment concentré ben je me
suis dit ça il vient de partir mais à y
regarder avec avec la tête dans les
mains et il était vraiment concentré
alors la tour prend d ici son regard une
menace qui pourrait exister un j'ai par
exemple g6 un truc comme ça et que tu
vois un bain de foule
ça peut marcher ça peut ne pas marcher
mais ça peut être un danger c'est ça bon
pour le couteau suisse de leurs défendre
mais complètement complètement temps ces
6 tu fait planer un danger tout le temps
surveiller ce que y'a pas tendre hommage
et ce qui marche c'est ce qu'il va faire
torah c'est un doublé tour à tour ses 7
août aura c'est récurrent b6 maintenant
voilà c'est une position vraiment
complexe pour l'instant maxime germé un
allié faire élire il fait une bonne
partie
mais voilà alors dans les autres matches
peu juste regarder les uns score 6 il y
en a zéro partie terminée chez la chine
et le reste du monde est pareil dans le
match inde états unis pour le moment
tout le monde le joueur venait à 0 0 et
a que nous qui avons fini deux parties
mais assez logiquement finalement cédé
parti qui était qui se diriger vers des
nuls et on va voir aller maxime qui est
concentré il lui reste douze minutes
contre 7
c'est peut-être une position finalement
plus agréable à jouer pour les blancs
pendant longtemps on a eu l'impression
que c'était plus maxime qui pressait
alors là et j'ai envie de dire c'est un
peu ça un peu comme la partie précédente
où tu as deux énormes atouts à long
terme
un peu le joueur surpression qui se fait
attaquer donc taxe est un peu ça et si
tu fais tout bien tu peux prétendre à
une victoire plus d'un an matériellement
on en est où il ya 2 4 6 contre 2 4 6
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya égalité deux
pions mais les pions h se font pas forte
impression en gros ce tour c'est 8 pour
liquider c'est le coup logique armée il
faut un peu calculé tour c'est un tour
ses huit tours ses limites trop bien ans
et 8 pour ses 8,3 sémites et peut-être
les blancs peuvent maintenant se diriger
de l'autre côté de l'échiquier pour
essayer de gagner le pion g7 et faire
parler des transats ou faut le défendre
absolument un peu pâle des nations
d'amérique ont perdu est bon sa peur
d'être sam de voir comment la banque ont
progressé mais en tout cas les dents
longues
non peut-être une nulle comme ça qui va
décider petit à petit mais je râle ça
peut jouer longtemps sans quand tu as
d'ailleurs un projet pour les blancs
peut-être c'est madame vers f4 ou trois
où je sais pas où j'ai simple et si la
dame par des fuites
un montage 6 des changes même suivi et
de loi du coup tu es voilà l'histoire un
deuxième tueur h deuxième étage de la
fusée moyens ça peut ça peut ça peut
créer mettre les blancs qui sont un peu
mieux au final ici hein parce que tu
puisses avoir l'idée de faire flamber 50
pour du tan c'est un miracle ou
peut-être mettre la dame en f4 jouer b4
pour prendre le contrôle de la casse
c'est simple puis le fou en b 5 et
peut-être à un moment donné neuf dames
services it easy way web écoute c'est
pas vraiment en train de voir des
défauts du fonds f5 les défauts cachés
c'est rare un ouais j'ai toujours su que
la française était forte je souhaitais
venir
donc c'est pour ça que maxime se jette
pas sur tours c'est 8,1 pour expliquer
un petit peu c'est vrai que ça paraît
traître le coup logique mais il doit il
doit pas trop aimé cette finale alors
après l'autre coup ça peut être fou et 4
fabien mais avec une idée assez
simpliste de faire d'un enfant h 4 e
match en match
voilà et puis peut-être des quatre ans
aussi en mai cette tour de ces deux c6
c'est une possibilité mais surtour c1 il
faut calculer des quatre oui mesdames 38
ans aux larges et on plonge basiques de
buzz en fait il marche il est plus
violent que de f3 mais oui on va les
mater à la violente mais bon ça se joue
au couperet c'est chacun en coupe ou
recours et les marins premier faux-pas
faut pas se louper un parce qu'après
tout reprendre comprend tour ses hits
qui sembleraient mater de ce côté là y'a
tout rachat matelot spots et
heureusement parce que surtout entre les
n 17 mais je raconte 1er mai aux achats
qui a pas mal contre 28 qui m'attendent
premier c'est fini donc il a fait fou et
quatre petits menace d'un micro atx 4
par le coup logique serait fou à troyes
où f 3 ouais mais f3 et visasfrance shit
faiblit encore plus sur les dames
proches 4 on a vu dans le land allemand
qui avait dit d'alger 3 tours s'est déjà
piquionne montré ferme mondial de thon
footsie perd car je me sens plus récent
clash 5 donc ça fait beaucoup de défauts
en un seul coup mais n'a pas tout dit
qu'ils gagnent autant mais bon qu'est ce
que t'en fais parce que vous accroissez
quand même le coup un peu solides
c'est ça si on pour grade solide mais
mais elle a réagi se montrer en dame
pour un f4 on fait tous retrouvés 6 3 8
on pourrait jouer un coup de courbet set
et là encore floues price trois années
noires sont très dangereux mais on se
raconte premier frappe en premier donc
ça joue vraiment c'est la difficulté de
ces variantes là c'est que ça va
toujours se joue autant prêt à celui qui
frappe en premier la rescousse
tu as dans les coups un peu bizarre qui
peuvent être en tout 24
d'accord sur d'apprendre que ferrer 3
août hors concours je le disais tu fais
tout reprendre les 600 premiers
peut-être où je sais pas quand vous
bougez pas ce constat changement oui oui
est il donc du coup il ya plus et menace
de maths et de faire un tour prend b6 et
j'attaque ça peut marcher
c'est juste pour montrer des idées
encore une fois pas content mais c'est
important ça le d'avoir toutes ces idées
là et après bien sûr calculé calcul est
calculé et trouver dans le sens ça
marche
et là quelle est concrètement possible
quoi il a fait froid écoute je n'aurais
jamais eu le courage de jouer ce coup
maxime qui prend thème pour un f5
alors là écoute ça va être très chaud
maxime quissac les films pièces mais qui
ouvre complètement le rad
donc c'est lui qui est le premier à
attaquer mais au prix d'un fou et donc
pourra pas sauver
donc là normalement tout reprend pour le
moment c'est pas intéressant parce que
la dame est encore en défense a encore
que jakub et 5
ouais on a vu les tours c8 tout
simplement ce genre de cas de figure
mais ok c'est même pas fini et est ce
que tient question j'entreprends ainsi
s'il y avait du roi à 8
dre faut calculer ce qu'ils avaient
droit à huit tours à ces forteresses
coup de l'ordi menace tout reprend qui
te dit la dame mais si tu prends tu peux
pas reprendre deux fois tout d'abord
d'un jet set et puis tu as toute emprise
et une comme ça tu sors ton emprise est
en train de faire changer des pièces que
tu as dame est pas si tu as plus attaqué
et j'ai trouvé qu'une pièce de mains ok
donc ce même ça s'échauffe ne te prends
mais si ça se regarde si on prend 24 ça
se regarde un joli personnes encore une
mais qui on prend le cas des affaires
par maxime il à la tour attaqué vaincu a
forcément prendre
il meurt à mener 5 1 et tours à schwyz
beaucoup de choses ils m'ont appelé
trois dames e3 donc je vous d'alger 3
toi tu vois je calcule pas je vais comme
ça je me dis jamais à l'abri si il faut
être trois
un truc comme ça et maintenant tour c1
avec l'idée que
tu menaces se situe à même avec les
plantes est parti avec les pièces les
plus racistes dont tu parlais bad as me
prend tour à la recette mais les gens
oui tous rachats ont montré que l'europe
il va se retrouver assez en sécurité
vers l'avant elle juste pour montrer un
coût qui donnera envie c'est être ça
enfin pas trop avec les honneurs puisque
tu te fais maths et mais un jardin
ça permet de faire cette attaque des
blancs permet de paralyser une pièce
d'attac noir exactement et ce pion à 6
on avait dit vrai ces problèmes du
huitième rang j'ai aussi pas que pour la
mesure de cette nature même pour montrer
qu'on regarde pas échec échec tourage 3
je dis bravo je gagne la dame tour c'est
je te défie la tour depuis la fin
naturelle troisième plus versée pour un
petit peu illustrait la force de la tacc
parfois pour défendre donc que très très
confiant je sais pas qu'est ce qui va se
passer devant d'année pour la fin du
tour pro v6 et partir sur notre
direction
mais bon il calcule bien il faut vite et
bien
alors juste pour profane à ok bon ça
c'est se tend de plus en plus d'uranium
il ya maintenant une pièce ouais donc
tout va jouer sur sur le sur notre
poulet iliad va être va être à cours à
court de temps mais il sait jouer vite
après se mettre aussi mal autant la r34
mais bon il doit regarder ton h4 et se
faire une idée sur le coup d'après à mon
avis mais parce que mes pur 4 est-ce que
tu as un proche 4 et si débile et en
province
l'arrière droit de suite et faut croire
en fait je sais plus vaste hors
compétition d'un v6 envie de le faire
mais peut-être bon sprint aura pris ce
point d'être on prend juste à sainte
maxime pour la 3 3 non je comprends les
a aimés moi je
vraiment fait d'un médecin alors ont été
effrayés par dams et 5000 veut roi est
fin et tout est joué comme un fils keto
vimont fou il tient de flicage blanche
c'est le battre méfions prend 1,4 et une
possibilité en v6 way endroit et lui le
tour des six encore le même truc obtenu
d'accord tourbe et 8
lamy non mais bon c'est pour me demanda
si même dans le détroit
joliette remettre un joli ou compagnes
surtout pour ses valeurs ses six les
tours des huit aussi peut-être
allons-nous adam provoqué la table sur
la colonne c'est pour l'exercice
je n'arrive pas à le faire d'avis
j'aimerais jouer cette partie parce que
c'est très cool c'est très amusant là
honnêtement jouer ce genre de partie
c'est juste un grand plaisir un fabien
j'imagine pour toi aussi parce que il ya
des attaques de partout et ça rend de
partout mais par contre j'aurais pas
forcément une préférence pour la couleur
ouais c'est intéressant pour les deux
suisses une partie qui fait plaisir
betts qui a deux pourquoi en faisant des
sas et c'est leur dire du s'ils nous
donnent raison s'il donne un truc
équitable donc c'est que c'est bien de
vue avec l'un ou l'autre
enfin citons julien snow faire pour le
mieux donc finalement un truc barman
mais j'adore ce genre de partie où les
deux joueurs attaquer ou des coudes
attaques peuvent servir de coups de
défense aussi se départit vraiment
intéressante à jouer mais c'est joli
c'est logique qu'on aime dieu maîtrise
sympa et l'attaquent peuvent peut valoir
de défense la défense peut valoir
d'attac et c'est vraiment vraiment des
parties extrêmement excitante à jouer et
c'est vrai que d'amuser ça que je
comprends qu'ils se précipitent pas
parce qu'à vrai dire que tant que la
dame est ici elle couvre aussi un peu le
roi alors c'est pas forcément la
première pièce que tu as envie de bouger
et voilà c'est prêt ou pas nous regarder
elle son maître d'échecs très souvent on
regarde ce qui se passe quand on fait
échec parce que sa force l'adversaire à
paris cette menace et ça peut juste très
bien se passer et chaque échec quand
même dans un courant le mat ou quelque
chose comme ça par contre c'est pas du
tout toujours la meilleure manière de
jouer
échec va te sert à rien c'est injuste a
attaqué droit qui m'apparaît la banane
ne serait pas gagné la partie s'est pas
au bout de 4
ben quoi donc donc des fois c'est mieux
de couper les cases de retraite du roi
et ensuite venir attaquer plutôt que d'y
aller frontalement et qu'ils puissent
payer la note
je regarde surtout râches moi c'est tout
ac 1 pour les blancs enfin la présence
d'ahmed 4 menacerait voilà c'est très
gentil parce que t'en rends v6 3,8 et
cette fois on n'a plus le temps passe
qu'est la tour c'est un qui sera en
l'air et le folk 3 et qu'on n'a pas de
couilles justement des chèques pour
continuer attaque et le fameux toro
victor s'est vite on va se rencontrer
rien n'est perdu 3 hoodlum france 3 le
gepci quoi la tour qui défend l' attaque
de trois pièces simultanée quoi écoute
c'est hyper compliqué mais vont tout
peut il a pris les cinq événements
l'ordinateur nantes maximy complètement
gagnant à reprendre des cinq j'ai peur
j'ai du mal à comprendre mieux que
s'attaque pas ça dépend pas d'eux c'est
juste tu passes ton tour quelques
baraques ce goût et c'était une position
à tous les coups étaient importants et
puis en plus tu vas laisser tout
reprendre et c'est peut-être mais là le
coup je prendrais 5 c'est un coup très
d'étonnant pour la c1 était logique les
marchés pas vraiment comme des
ordinateurs il proposait tour ces trois
à lui bon c'était difficile de se
décider entre les 2 mai puis on prend
des 5 c'était vraiment pas le coup
logique fab
non loin de là basses attaques basses et
des combats c'est un peu je passe mon
tour et c'est pas le genre de position
où on envie de passer son tour alors
maintenant qu'est-ce qui va faire alors
peut-être alors tour c'est ingénieux
point c'est tout rachat maintenant à nos
moutons promettant des foins à fond
l'année puis la dame un peu ce qu'on
fait c'est surtout ces trois qui a tour
à tour h1 parle je me suis mélangé les
pinceaux et tour à 3 du goût mais
n'importe que le couple pendant tout peu
importe le nom mes lordi l'autre qui dit
c'est plus un petit tour h 1 e de ce
qu'est ce que tu as mangé de suite les
mater segment irina les super ça sur
échec les brèves de
on va te contourner avec un damage de on
va te faire d'un spray colonna et tout
ça tu n as rien avec les blancs j'ai
l'impression que la 3d c'est sympa tu te
trompes fait plus 1 donc tu veux tu veux
le circuit derrière matt a en fait il
veut menacer sa bien aimée d'accord
c'est ça son dj réfectoire à 3 tours h
un tempo rome deux hommes 3,5 j'imagine
ok bah ça va on a compris pourquoi des
jeux comme ça dit je m'attellerai dans
le coin il veut mater il veut que les
temps en v6 menace avec le fou qui vous
ok mais alors dit nous dit que ça ne
marche pas du tout encore faut-il être
précis et c'est pas facile jeunes est
une fois de plus maxime très bien autant
avec 7 minutes 30 un peu plus me contre
une minute 22 mai déjà la même veine
regarde s'il ya besoin et par la cia
dame de demain oui mais clairement la
cherchez plus
ça veut déjà dire que t'es mis avec les
noirs ouais pareil séminaire la
confiance ses paupières nul
oui il y aura de maths en héros à 20 par
un jeune des deux puis on va te ramener
vers la fin on te rabat et antonin les
automates minimes a rappelé un bon match
et minima parce que là en fait attendre
un coup très intéressant c'est avec 36
pions e5 paris cheikh sène qui ont pris
dans l'escarcelle et on attaque ou grand
le roi qui ont encore bouger quelque
part même pas de délai soit 3 et manger
aussi c'est que tu reprends des 5
comprend des scènes courage 3 mais la
dame donc l'europe même pas troller sur
la troisième rangée ça qu'on sait plus
faire beaucoup de cases disponibles tout
ça elle prend des sacs étaient vraiment
une grosse erreur mais il a pu vouloir
éviter à toi je joue une fois ça mange
pas de pain bon s'il le ferait tout le
temps ça fera nu et l'on pourra déçus
parce qu'on a alors dit après je sais
pas
sans la jauge peut-être qu'on dira oui
bravo il assure grippe a je sais pas
façon les gens n'ont pas le choix alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe roi des deux
roues
je pense qu'on va le faire d'un proche
tu dis que toute variation sur wade 2 tu
pourras toujours te réfères tour h2k il
fera peut-être roi des huns mesdames des
quatre noms saverne hyper bien ils ont
sexy dans les colonies mais après c'est
le genre de truc qui peut rendre fou qu
as tu calcules tu vois toujours une
défense ce fou qui défend à chaque
parent bédard et 32 ans il faudra un
terroir c1 et etc
et puis tu sais que si tu perds tu
m'aimes match en l'air et que peut-être
nul tu as les russes à deux points
derrière équipe en classement c'est pas
si mal nulle en fait et surtout cinq
derniers 3 tournons vers d autres
autrement d'approuver le faire parce que
j'avais vu de base et on vous parlait
nulle part aux dames des deux tours h 2
on se prend non finale et si vraiment on
detroit on n'a plus à défendre ce que tu
vois je me joue alors horrible genre
truc horrible
il est très joli hein ouais le pion qui
tient dans sa main il a fait un croix
des trois tours prend des saints qui la
trouvaient trop généreuse de quoi
peut-être la faute du coup je me connais
pas trop le choix il faut prendre je
vous prends et donc tout relâchement
imagine par exemple j'ai gagné la dame
et la tour en prison c'est fini donc en
fait il va se trouver avec deux tours
contre la dame y aura les trois pions le
ghg ça c'est un truc comme ça
il veut prendre de la tour donne 35 il
ya doublé c'est toujours la barrière des
formes par exemple et puis après les
pillards mais ouais mais c'est beaucoup
c'est trop bien bref faire gaffe plasma
p4p 5 et qui commence pas ta bah oui
peut-être un peu plus précis que ça mais
c'est ce genre d'idée il faudra encore
la finir femmes m'apprendre à la bande à
la grande île en plus un don par mail et
sur wade deux tours prend b3 vous prend
b3 à la demande et je vais dire dam des
caps damas quatre à une proposition de
nuls quelque part chez les filles
n'hésitent eu aucun qui a proposé
bah oui quoi faire pour les noirs pas il
peut refuser pour refuser mais non elle
a fait nul nul signé china est donc tout
va se jouer ici je pense que garage qui
n'a eu raison d'accepter pour mettre
toute la pression tête pour permettre à
yann de deux mètres afin de la mettre la
pression en plus sur maxime il va les
prendre le pion à 6 pas prendre l'eau
chaude à voir bien sûr mais au moins tu
apprendras si c'était plus trop m2
matrouh pourra et puis après du coup si
elle même plus besoin d'avoir la dame la
défense du roi ttt large pas si tu
gagnes assise sûr mais là dessus est
large mais tu disais un époux qui était
joueur peut-être à sortir un côté à côté
rue s'il avait senti un fab bâle en
suisse peuvent se faire damer fin j'ai
passé mais tu peux même et c'est
peut-être de données doivent intéresser
encore aller mais c'est vrai qu'une
victoire de maxime la fab
ça va être très très bien l'équipe
européenne qui jouerait la camif en
compagnie de plus que jamais des états
unis qu'ils se sont plantés le major et
là je sais pas ce qu'ils vont monter
lundi
je suis regardé si tu veux dire c'est
les ap ils font quoi quand l'un des dix
ans à le jouer de mettre leur art tout
aille à son casier qui ravive en croire
la nuit m donc il ya un an et demi pour
l'instant et
il n'a qu'à vichy et baby chien beaucoup
mieux beaucoup mieux combien terrain et
il reste des filles quand les robots
contredire il n'accroche mazzarri quatre
jours pour la ok vin l'une ou l'autre
mais de façon crush qui s'en sortent pas
trop mal donc peut-être un nul en vue ou
gestion équipes peuvent gagner à larache
avec une super héros de crush avec les
noirs qui est mieux c'est chaud c'est
sûr il faut quand même pour nous que
maxime l'emporta oui mais m'écoute c'est
très très très bien parti c'était très
chaud comme d'artistes et bouillant cela
partait dans tous les sens et c'est
parti dans le bon sens en fait
maxime tu es du courage qu'elle sacrifie
se fout là pour entrer que les tours la
dame est une hypoxie pas montré la très
précis pour défendre avec cette idée là
dessus on prend des 5 et ensuite il a
perdu sa dame donc écouter ça se dessine
tous à tour c1 dames fc enquête chèque
wendy l'eau pure race en deuil et c'est
commencer peut-être à faire pousser mais
bon il aura car des gars en vie oui mais
le truc c'est que pendant que la tour
des fonctions au moins les bananes c'est
loin oui mais regardons du psg 5 par
exemple il appathurai froid ça qui est
bien avec la dame non mais on est bien
on a tous poussé mais on va tout pousse